Guten Morgen Tim.
Er stand im Spiegel wach.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 280 eure Weihnachts Podcast Versorgung und Kongress Vorbereitung der letzte Podcast hingehören bist in diesem Jahr.
Wir schreiben den 21 Dezember 2018 und danach geht's ja einfach mal steil in Weihnachts und Kongress Vorbereitung.
Für manche ist es das gleiche.
Ja danach ich weiß jetzt willst du ja sagen du bist schon seit mich echt wie unprofessionell Kongresses nur richtig geil aber da erst zwei Tage vorher dran denkt.
Inder Leipzig sind schon irgendwie weit über hundert Leute seitdem 17.
Ich weiß ich war auch schon kurz vor Ort und es ist ein betriebsam ist Gewusel und es ist einfach absurd wie viele Highlander schon.
Bespielt werden und so weiter na ja zum Kongresshalle heute auch noch mal was sagen ansonsten haben wir vor allem jetzt hier noch als Besonderheit für heute eingeladen und zwar katharinen.
Hallo katharinen.
Hi
Schön dass du es geschafft hast katharin tai auch bekannt als Whitey Chan auf den Twitter Netzen du hast schon so eine gewisse Twitter Sichtbarkeit bisher dann auch eher so ein bisschen,
Netz offen.
Ja alles wieder zumindest aber da ist es dann meistens einen Mix aus essensfotos und runs über China.
Wenn ich das so anscheinend entscheidend wollen sich Leute das anschauen aber.
Rans über China.
Rand und essen das geht immer eins zwei Sachen die immer.
Genau damit hast du auch schon bisschen verraten warum wir dich heute eigentlich dabei haben wollten weil wir wollten mal so ein bisschen über China reden und das wäre dann auch tun zweiten Teil dieser Sendung vielleicht noch kurz zu dir du bist Politikwissenschaftlerin
studierst around the world und das hast du jetzt aber abgeschlossen und bist jetzt in Boston gelandet am MRT,
hast du heute eine Doktorandenstelle und nicht zu vergessen podcasterin.
Hast du mich auch ein Podcast über asiatische Angelegenheiten kann man das so sagen.
Ja im Großen und Ganzen also wir müssen zwei China Leute eigentlich den Podcast machen dass es dir denn vor allem bin ich in Jesus sprachigen Teil der Welt so,
Taiwan Hongkong und die Volksrepublik und wenn wir dann über andere Teile der Welt reden uns öfters noch Experten ran die uns auch über Südostasien und andere Teile des Kontinents erzählen können.
Davon von auswärts Podcast von auswärts. De Empfehlung für euren Po.
Jetzt müssen erstmal das Feedback einsammeln und ja Fake News bei Logbuch Netzpolitik so siehts aus ne stellt sich raus.
Einmal da haben wir einmal da haben wir ja noch das fact-checking gemacht ja wir haben ja tatsächlich wir haben es versucht und haben wirklich vor der Sendung hier gesessen haben gesagt das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen,
unklar beschrieben ob da jetzt eine Bürgerinitiative gibt oder nicht und.
Besen Körner.
In kleßen-görne haben wir gesagt wir rufen da jetzt mal an das war natürlich nicht möglich weil die haben ja keinen.
Sie hatten sie hatten auch Festnetz irgendwie.
Das Rathaus ist nicht direkt in kleßen-görne.
Wir haben das Rathaus strategisch außerhalb des außerhalb des der Versorgungslücke platziert oder die haben als ein erschlossenes Rathaus Rathaus wo man anrufen kann war aber keiner da.
Klingel Aldi Telefon da leise vor sich hin.
Und inzwischen gibt es auch auf heise.de dann eine Richtigstellung in der der der Bürgermeister von kleßen-görne sagt,
wir hoffen auf eine zügige Baugenehmigung und es ist eine offensichtliche Fehlinformation wenn.
Der Minister Herr scheuer auf potenzielle Probleme bei der Genehmigung hinweist,
denn es wird hier offenbar fehlinterpretiert es gibt keine Proteste aus den Reihen der rund 360 Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner die freuen sich alle auf ihren,
Anschluss an die Versorgung und sind,
keine hinterwäldlerisch and Strahlungs Gegner darauf diese,
Feststellung wird Wert gelegt und das freut uns dass es nicht so ist und wir hoffen dass es dabei Versorgung geben wird.
Genau alles wird gut in Brandenburg ist nämlich auch dringend nötig weil von um die Ecke vom Forsthaus schön hauen
musst du berichten für berichtet werden dass ein Ortsteil von Fürstenberg Havel und auch ich habe mal kurz nachgeschaut und gar nicht so weit weg von Fürstenberg Havel und das ist dann schon eher einer der größeren Orte im
wo in der Region in Brandenburg ja und da gab es dann halt ein Brand in dem schönen Forsthaus schön Horn aber leider konnte auch hier kein Notruf gewählt werden mit dem Mobiltelefon bei kein Netz,
aber das muss man sagen wenn man Notruf macht dann greift man auch auf alle Netze zurück und ja gab aber keine alle Netze und von daher,
musst du da erstmal jemand zwei Kilometer mit dem Auto fahren um dort erstmal wieder in den Versorgungsbereich zu kommen also insofern höchste Note in Brandenburg.
Bitte schließen gerne anschließen bevor uns das wegbrennen.
Flight ist schon ab.
Seitdem wir wissen es nicht deswegen ist auch die ganze Zeit schon gehabt deswegen musst du auch keiner mehr was von der Bürgerinitiative also mir das gesagt Sonntag.
Dann haben wir ja über die über offene Gesetze gesprochen,
und haben angemerkt dass es ja sinnvoll wäre noch die Domain offene Gesetze Minus im Minus Internet zu betreiben damit die Menschen auch wissen dass es im Internet ist und.
So wie die anderen Gesetze im Internet.
Die anderen gesetze-im-internet und wir wurden darauf freundlich darauf hingewiesen von offene Gesetze de hallo Love Netflix wir haben uns eure Kritik zu Herzen genommen es gibt jetzt auch offene Gesetze - im Minus Internet,
punkt.de das begrüßen wir und wir,
begrüßt das ausdrücklich und wir bitten alle jetzt Ihre Domains umzustellen auf im Internet auch Amazon sollte dann jetzt in der Weihnachtszeit noch umschalten,
außer dem Internet bekommt.
Genauer weitere Informationen findet ihr auf Logbuch Netzpolitik im internet.de.
Aber dann wissen will ich noch Jens hin Jens kubieziel dass er schon früher eine Domain hatte die lautete Anonymität - im Internet und da wiederum macht das ja Sinn.
Behandelt ja Anonymität im Internet versus am und Anonymität außerhalb des Internets. De die von der Konkurrenz betrieben wurde.
Also da sind wir froh dass das alles seinen richtigen lauf hat im Internet.
Jawollo Amazon schon erwähnst aber sein könnte noch ein paar mehr du meinst dazu nehmen Ihre Dateien im Internet.
Punkt.de wäre z.b. ganz kurz hat ein Amazon-Kunde seine gespeicherten Daten nach der datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Abrufen wollen also entsprechendes Auskunftsersuchen gestellt was kann wie es da geht aber offensichtlich gibt's da ein Weg.
Da die Katharina nocun mach das doch da hat das doch auch gemeint Buch drüber geschrieben und.
Ja ich wüsste jetzt nicht wo ich hin klicken muss aber es sonst hätte ich da jetzt noch ein Tipp gegeben wie einfach das doch ist aber ehrlich gesagt.
Nee da muss man schon mit der geht's nicht irgendwie so ein Knopf divide Twitter du musst das schon irgendwie das richtige legalize hinschicken und dann.
Na ja okay verstanden,
picking doch mehrere Monate auf einem nicht so weit entfernten Planeten aus zwei Monate später schon wurde in ein ZIP-Archiv bereitgestellt und darin befand sich 50 Dateien.
Mit diesem personenbezogenen Daten allerdings auch 1700 WAV-Datei,
wird eine PDF-Datei mit chronologisch unsortierten Transkripten darüber was halten die WAV-Dateien in diese WAV-Dateien man kann sich schon vorstellen sind Aufnahmen aus einer Alexa spricht Dose.
Nicht seiner sondern der von jemand anderem der von jemand an.
Anderer Entschuldigung noch besser.
1700x welche alexa Spracheingabe von irgendjemand anderem wenn man jetzt also die
der sich jetzt hat die Frage stellt ob man sich so ein Ding in die Bude stellen möchte ja,
passiert wie jede jede einzelne Interaktion die man damit auslöst offenbar speichert und dann auf Nachfrage irgendwelchen anderen zufälligen Personen gibt ja das möchte man wirklich nicht haben und genau aus diesem Grund.
Warnen wir ja auch seit jeher davor so etwas in Betrieb zu nehmen und es ist ein es ist einfach ein riesiges.
Riesiges wunderschönes Problem aber.
Amazon hat gesagt ja sie hatten also relativ schnell verstanden dass es sich da um eine menschlichen Fehler handelte ja wer auch immer irgendwie Dill,
die 1700 Dateien nach ausgefüllt und den Personen geschickt hat.
Sollte das nicht tun sie haben das innerhalb von 72 Stunden an die zuständige Datenschutzbehörde gemeldet weil das ja ihre Pflicht sei und es tut uns sehr tut es sehr leid und.
Der betroffene Nutzer und jetzt ist natürlich der. Betroffen ist hier die Person die diese 1700,
WAV-Dateien angefertigt hat mithilfe ihres Echo Lautsprecher und das ist ja hier die von der von der Datenschutzverletzungen betroffene Person die hat erst vier Wochen nach der Panne,
Meldung darüber bekommen was glaube ich nicht in Ordnung ist liebes aber so das ist was.
Nee ich glaube das ist eher so im Bereich von unverzüglich oder so.
Nicht in Ordnung aber alles kein Problem denn Amazon hat die Person bereits entschädigt,
bekommt eine kostenlose Prime Mitgliedschaft und zwei weitere Echo Lautsprecher.
Super.
Alles gut sorry Pass auf wir haben festgestellt das ist ja auch ein bisschen mager 1700 Dateien wir geben dir mal ein paar mehr von diesen von diesen Dingern dann kannst du dir noch eine Wohnzimmerwand in die Küche stellen und auf der Toilette oder so.
Sehr schön ach die haben sich haben sich mit unserem Messer in Finger geschnitten hier sind noch zwei Pistolen dazu.
Und ich glaube das ist der erste dsgvo induzierte dsgvo fail aber diese Daten aus Abfrage ginge.
Sozusagen ja.
Also super Amazon Spitze der feingemacht.
Das könnt ihr noch lustig werden da sieht man mal dass auf diese ganzen Prozesse noch eine Weile brauchen werden bis sie wirklich richtig greifen andererseits ist ja eigentlich fehlt natürlich hier das ist diese Datei überhaupt.
Also das ist halt einfach ein Systemfehler von wie eben Amazon Alexa funktioniert.
Es ist es ist einfach.
Mach Erkennung in der Cloud Savanne scheiß Idee.
Und das ist alles gar nicht gut und es ist dort nicht schön dass du was gespeichert wird und es war von vornherein eine schlechte Idee und ich hatte ein Film.
Aber es ist doch so einfach.
Ja super funktioniert der vor Jahren auch mal sein Buchbeitrag zugeschrieben der mir in dem Zusammenhang wieder,
Einfeldt in welcher Nummer verlinken Sensoren der Cloud wo ich diesen,
Begriff damals noch meinte tatsächlich zu prägen also als und auch als negativ zu prägen inzwischen wenn man jetzt zwischen Sensoren und klaut googelt dann ist das schon völlig normaler Sprachgebrauch des,
Cloud Sensoren hat die in eure in euer Leben Tentakeln um dort mehr Daten zu bekommen und,
das ist jetzt ein ganz normaler ganz normaler Ausdruck schon.
Sensorik das ist jetzt sozusagen der neue Trend.
Solange solange jetzt nicht noch ankommen mit Orgon.
Früher früher hat man noch sozusagen sind so aufgebaut wie das Wetter zu erfassen jetzt erfasst das Wetter ein.
Ja aber das ist tatsächlich.
Also das ist tatsächlicher das was sich dahinter verbirgt dass die großen Unternehmen wie jetzt Facebook oder Google ja tatsächlich einfach.
Einen deckeneffekt dabeihaben welche Daten sie aus deinem Leben noch bekommen konnten,
durch ihre Online-Plattform facebook ist jetzt nicht so als würde facebook.es gibt es irgendeine Interaktion die du mit der facebook oder auf der Amazon oder der Google Seite,
haben könntest die dort nicht.
Vernünftig erfasst und ins Datenmodell integr integriert wird ja und dann haben sie immer gesagt a-ok.
Wir können jetzt werden die Leute sie dir auf unserer Facebook-Seite jetzt müssen wir die aber manchmal sind die frech und gehen in den Rest des Internets ja,
dann müssen wir gucken dass wir die da auch erfassen machen wenn Like-Button hin,
so okay wunderbar jetzt haben wir irgendwie da unsere Sensoren und können das Verhalten dort noch erfassen dann haben wir wieder für gesorgt dass sie immer Nachricht lesen aber gut dann bring mal die Nachrichten bei uns rein und dann kommt irgendwann notwendigerweise der schritte sage okay wir müssen dies
in den Momenten erfassen wo die nicht am Bildschirm hängen weil das dass das ist wir haben da den deckeneffekt erreicht also geben wir den hier so eine Dose stell dir den in Zimmer und hören den
beim beim Essen machen zu und beim Kinder machen.
Und dann haben wir da auch noch mal Daten.
Da kann man den denn demnächst auch mit Alexa einfach so abfragen Alexa spielen wir Leute beim Kinder machen vor.
Wir sollten das ja nicht mehr sagen ne Alexa lösch dich.
Scheiß drauf.
Übersetzer sind dann immer diese bedauerlichen Einzelfälle und diese bedauerlichen Einzelfälle die häufen sich halt ne,
das ist jetzt der bedauerlicher Einzelfall dass sie es preisgegeben haben aber man fragt sich ernsthafte warum liegen bei denen überhaupt diese ganzen Aufzeichnungen Warum löschen die die nicht,
warum kann die gewonnen kann da überhaupt jemand drauf zugreifen.
Der Bommel him sie diese Information überhaupt erst dass du so ein Teil da drin.
Naja ist nicht dass ich davon ausgegangen wäre ja.
Und das Ding ist er immer an also das ist so alles was ich darüber weißt ob dafür dass ich nicht haben möchte.
Der ist ja nur an wenn du den ansprichst R&S kannst ihr Leuten erzählt dass ihr wieso der ist doch nicht an der ist ja nur an wenn ich den anspreche ja,
wie hat der das gehört dass du den angesprochen hast
nee nee nee nee das Mikrofon ist ja aus bis ich den bis ich den anspreche sowie diese diese freiwillig Forschung nervös sein feststellen irgendwie es gibt ein Gehirn Impuls bevor du überhaupt in die Entscheidung gefasst hast genauso geht dieses Amazon Alexa nur dann an,
kurz bevor Du es ansprichst.
Ja es gab ja auch schon kenne ich dich da auch nicht so genau aber es gab er dann auch schon so ein paar gerichtliche ersuchen bei Amazon solche sprach Informationen aus.
Von Prime Betroffenen Wohnung vorzulegen und ich glaube da ist auch was vorgelegt worden das habe ich jetzt aber nur eine Erinnerung habe gerade keinen,
keine passende URL im Kopf und das natürlich ein generelles Problem mit dem wir uns in der Zukunft der nahen auch bekannt als Gegenwart rumschlagen.
Nur zur Vollständigkeit das wöchentliche Facebook Datenleck sei auch noch erwähnt haben sie jetzt was haben sie diesmal gut hinbekommen.
Im September 2018 konnten externe Programme auf mehr Facebook Fotos zugreifen als sie durften also quasi laut,
laut eigentlicher Berechtigung dieser Programme durften also es geht darum diese Facebook Apps na das war jetzt hatte ich gebe einem Drittanbieter den Blick auf Fotos in der Chronik frei aber in diesem Fall waren es dann,
alle auch für andere Zwecke eingesetzt oder gespeicherten fACEBOOK fotos beispielsweise die jetzt irgendwie für Marketplace oder Stories gedacht waren also ein.
Im Prinzip vor dem vor der vor der Fülle der Menge an Datenlecks bei Facebook relativ kleines kleines Problem.
Denn es gibt gerade bei Netflix eh keine sehr schöne Zusammenstellung von Simon Räbiger der einfach gesagt hat die schönsten Datenskandale 2018 nur bei Facebook,
das irgendwie so im Juli sind dann mal zwei im September sitzt zwei im Dezember sind drei unter anderem auch.
Das Facebook dann mit bestimmten Unternehmen.
Besondere Daten die es hatte wo sie mehr Zugriff auf Nutzerdaten bekamen als gewöhnlich also wie so eine freundliche Zusammenarbeit,
Netflix und Spotify durften z.b. die private Nachrichten lesen die man sich immer Facebook,
Tipps für Netflix natürlich interessant ob die Leute gerade Netflix and chill machen ne und da muss man natürlich auch die privaten Nachrichten schauen App Hilfe.
Da wir wissen wann was die Leute gerade fühlen damit man das richtige Angebot macht.
Sod sod das was für eine.
Was für eine datenplattformen sich Leute da begeben haben und.
Ich kann tatsächlich nur hoffen dass er prinzipiell eigentlich für einen verlorenen Posten immer gebucht diese Facebook Geschichte,
weil diese dezentralen sozialen Netzwerke eben weniger einfach nutzbar sind und irgendwie auch den netzwerkeffekt bisher nicht erreichen konnten,
in der Breite um diesem Spuk Facebook dann irgendwann auch mal ein Ende zu bereiten aber vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht gelingt das ja doch irgendwann noch.
Aber habt ihr nicht das Gefühl dass in eurem sozialnetzwerk Leute aus Facebook also bei mir zumindest dann der Uni sind immer weniger Leute auf Facebook das wird wirklich weniger habe ich das Gefühl dass er rückgängig.
Ich hoffe dass es weniger wird ich hoffe nur dass die also im Moment ist das ja so dass du dann sagst ja ich nur ich bin nicht mehr bei Facebook ich mache jetzt nur noch insta,
ja was auf Facebook gehört und ich schreibe es dir über WhatsApp was auf Facebook gehört und das Problem Facebook loszuwerden ist einmal dass die Nutzer denen abwandern aber,
auch dass die irgendwohin abwandern was Facebook nicht mit dem riesigen Haufen Geld den sie haben sich einfach nur kaufen kann und das ist glaube ich etwas was vielleicht übersehen wird wenn,
Menschen sagen ja
MySpace ist auch immer noch mal eingegangen und StudiVZ hat sich auch nicht durchgesetzt da mal Oma immer gedacht dass da geht die Welt jetzt unter und genauso wird Facebook Eingehen einer facebook hat aber einfach mal ein paar Milliarden mehr.
Um sich.
Im Prinzip so gut wie jede Konkurrenz zu kaufen und es sei denn man geht man wandert wirklich in eine dezentrale ab und verfestigt sich dort dauerhaft auf eine Weise die irgendwie nicht kommerziell.
Und wir werden wenngleich noch über Konkurrenz reden wo sich Facebook nicht so ohne weiteres einkaufen kann also da gibt's durchaus noch ein paar andere Szenarien.
Aber die ist ja dann dies dann jetzt wirklich nicht unbedingt besser da die hat ja die gleichen Probleme ja.
Das wollte ich damit auch nicht sagen.
Dann kannst du dir immer Ausreden von dem du von wem du beobachtet wirst.
Genau du kannst ja wir haben Country und Western.
Genau nicht so richtig aussuchen von wem sind beobachtet werden konnten waren die Teilnehmer der G20 Demonstrationen in Hamburg im letzten Jahr.
Wie in einer tatsächlicher beispiellosen in einem beispiellosen Fall hat sich ja dann Hamburg entschieden,
die Hamburger Strafverfolgungsbehörden zu sagen wir möchten.
Sie haben einmal unsere eigenen Bild und Videodaten Polizisten,
haben dann ja irgendwie so auf Anja Videokameras unter das Geschehen festzuhalten Beweise zu sichern für den Fall dass irgendjemand dort,
vielleicht eine Straftat begeht oder zur Erfassung der Lage und.
Dann haben sie aber darüber hinaus gesagt wir möchten gerne dass ihr
ihr liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger eure Bilder bei uns in einer Plattform hochladet damit wir die analysieren können und da ging es natürlich dann vor allem nicht nur um Bilder auf den Menschen
Straftaten begehen sondern eigentlich aus dem allgemeine Lage Bilder weil du,
in denen ja unter Umständen die Leute auch mal ohne ohne Vermummung sehen kannst ja dann haben sie versucht da diese Daten irgendwie zu analysieren.
Mit tatsächlich eigentlich auch lächerlichen erfolgen na die haben ja glaube ich nur wenige Personen identifiziert haben darüber berichtet und eigentlich hat ihn das am Ende gar nichts gebracht,
Partykracher ist was erlaube Polizei da nämlich diese biometrischen Gesicht Daten,
von Person ohne Tatverdacht zu erstellen für unbestimmte Zeit zu speichern und dann eben für die für den Abgleich mit Tatverdächtigen zu nutzen sagte auch
der Datenschutzbeauftragte Johannes Caspar der jetzt die Löschung dieses kompletten dieser kompletten Daten angeordnet hat er ist seit längerer Zeit mit,
denen im Streit und sagt das ist was ihr der tut ist illegal denn eine betroffene Person hat auch keinen Rechtsbehelf sich dagegen zu wehren bei dir gar keine Kenntnis hat dass Sie sich in dieser Datensammlung befindet,
also wir haben hier eine Situation von in Hamburg G20 das waren ja wie viele Menschen haben wir demonstriert irgendwie in der Region 100000.
Falls die Zahl nicht mehr die da offiziell geschätzt wurde aber ne Menge.
Weiß jetzt auch nicht die genaue Einschätzung bei welchem Demonstration,
riesige Proteste in der ganzen Stadt über über mehrere Tage und die Menschen sind dort jetzt eben erfasst worden,
bei der Ausübung ihrer ihres Grundrechts auf Versammlungsfreiheit und
befinden sich jetzt in dieser Datenbank wissen das aber nicht und das ist natürlich nicht in Ordnung
wenn man dort ohne Kenntnis in dieser Form erfasst wird jetzt ist es so der Johannes Kasper das jetzt angeordnet und der Innensenator Andy grote könnte jetzt vor dem Verwaltungsgericht Hamburg klagen.
Wenn er sein Instrumentarium weiterhin als rechtskonform ansieht,
die sagt das Herz keine Ergebnisse gegeben die haben ja viele Terabyte analysiert 17 Terabyte waren das 32000,
Daten Einzeldateien,
ich weiß es nicht genau oder 100er arbeite ich sogar also alles der totale total skurrile Sachen und ist eigentlich gut dass das da jetzt die Löschung angeordnet ist und wir werden sehen ob er,
ob du die Hamburger Polizei.
Die das nämlich eigentlich in Zukunft von vom Projekt zum Prozess werden lassen möchte sich den beugt oder das ganze Ding jetzt auch noch vor die Gericht.
Und wer das mit den ganzen G20 aus welchen Gründen auch immer nicht so richtig mitbekommen hat und sich denkt sowieso das war noch alles linke Terroristen und mal gut dass er mal einer ordentlich drauf gehalten hat
dem sei noch mal in unserem
Oberlehrerin Sendungen empfohlen mich Logbuch Netzpolitik 225 vom 10. Juli 2017 mit dem schönen Titel dringende Bitte ein Logbuch Netzpolitik Spezial mit John F Nebel
und ja Berichterstattung von der Front und dort erhaltet ihr dann Einblicke in das damalige Geschehen,
die sich nicht so unbedingt überall Nein zu allen Zeitungen wieder fanden geschweige denn im politischen Rückblick der heutzutage so stattfindet wenn aber Haupt.
Dann ist ja in dieser Woche fact-checking ein großes Thema.
Wo ich will das.
Müssen wir bekommen noch mal zu Facebook und vielleicht auch kurz zu unserem Intro wir mussten ja leider diese kleinen die kleinen Seitenhieb auf den Spiegel des tube jetzt leid aber der muss natürlich sein.
Tatsächlich eigentlich ein großes großes fürchterliches disaster beim Spiegel hat ein,
Reporter gearbeitet der sehr sehr viele Auszeichnungen für seine Arbeit bekommen hat und dann stellte sich heraus dass er in weiten Teilen seine Geschichten.
Erfunden hat geht's interessanterweise aber auch für um so blöde Sachen wurde sag warum warum denkt er sich denn so ein Mist aus das hätte er ja auch.
Also die ist die Story wäre ja hätte ja funktioniert muss halt jetzt nicht sagen dass man aus dem einen Kaffee diesen Turm sehen kann wenn die Dinger Inhalt 3 km auseinander sind also auf so dumme Fehler ja sie hat jetzt nicht,
politische Fake News verbreitet.
Nee aber hat er hat schon ganz essentielle Plots überhaupt erst
mal in den Raum gestellt die ist so nicht gab und mit Personen anspreche ich gesprochen von denen keinerlei
niemand irgendeine Kenntnis hat und die schon essenziell dann für die eigentliche Geschichte waren und ich denke wenn du in dem Modus dann erstmal drin bist oder denkst du alicia schonmal ganz geil und jetzt hier noch ein bisschen,
besser ich saß hier und ich hörte die Glocken in der Ferne und der Wind wehte mir die nassen.
Blätter ins Gesicht dann dann dann bis er halt irgendwie schon auf dem lyrischen trip.
Genau und dann hat er die ganze Zeit Auszahlung also man muss einfach sagen das ist ein tragischer Fall auch für diese Person ist muss er in irgendeiner Form krankhaft.
Ja und vor allem für den Spiegel der sich ja jetzt quasi anhören lassen muss wie sie selber ja auch früh immerhin verstanden haben und der mir auch relativ offensiv jetzt damit,
umgehen oder offen damit zu mir ist oben gehen dann halt ihre eigene checking Abteilungen oder wie auch immer das,
intern heißt Chefredaktion Überprüfung weil sie sind ja.
Dafür bekannt sind ein besonders gutes fact-checking zu betreiben aber du kannst jetzt nicht einfach mal irgendeine Story schreiben und dann erscheint die so
sofort
Sonne Release schonmal einer gegen und hinterfragt ist das eigentlich belegt und wenn dieser Mechanismus dann halt auch nicht funktioniert hat dann ist es natürlich dann auch schon eher ne systemische Frage hier so also geht das noch.
Wobei dazu also gerade indem in in der Reportage die Spiegel seiner über das Thema geschrieben hat stand ja auch drin dass man das etwas defekt Checker machen ist ja,
nachzuprüfen als die Prüfung war sie auch irgendwie Einwohnerzahl stimmt und so aber die rufen jetzt nicht unbedingt die Leute noch mal an und hatte also das zumindest beschreibt wir die Arbeit der,
fr Kakadu geschrieben im Artikel und tatsächlich hat der auch,
E-Mails gefälscht also als dann irgendwie der sein Kollege ihm auf der Spur war hat er tatsächlich Screenshots von E-Mails gezeigt um zu beweisen dass seine Geschichten stimmen und E-Mails hatte auch selber gefälscht also wo du dann um Beweise gebeten und hat dann die Beweise noch mal gefälscht,
also es geht noch.
Das ist schon.
Dass er seine Grenzen hat ist mir natürlich vollkommen klar und ja es ist auch in gewisser Hinsicht schon mit so einer kriminellen Energie zu tun die am Start ist da ist ja sicherlich irgendwo eine Grenze gesetzt am Ende
ist das auch aber eine Realität mit der man sich
im abfinden muss und dann muss natürlich einen Weg gefunden werden wie man hier vielleicht weitere Prüfsteine in so ein Prozess mit einbauen kann ohne jetzt auch gleich das komplette Vertrauensverhältnis zu den Journalisten gegenüber auf.
Das ist ja das eigentliche Problem dass oder das was ich daran was mir daran nicht gefällt das ist jetzt Wasser auf den Mühlen der A.
Dich immer gesagt haben Fake News.
Zieh den ganzen Tag von der Lügenpresse reden weil sie nicht schreiben das gestern wieder in einem Dorf dass es nicht gibt auf auf dem Dorfbrunnen Hammel geschichtet wurde oder so ne irgend also so ein.
So ein Scheiß und es ist wirklich dramatisch.
Didia das Ausmaß für die.
Für für die gesellschaftliche Lage in Deutschland gerade der Spiegel geht natürlich großartig damit um oder geht verantwortungsbewusst und offensiv damit um hat auch das große Glück des selber.
Bekanntgeben zu können und nicht durch andere.
Aufgedeckt bekommen hinzubekommen mehr.
Aufgedeckt zu bekommen und wir können hoffen dass das dass er dir die richtigen Lehren draus gezogen werden nicht nur beim Spiegel sondern auch bei anderen Medien.
Und ja ansonsten ist das ein.
Bin ja schon froh dass es nicht bei spielerplus.
Hinter Tiere Peru.
Fact-checking hat also in unseren Zeiten immer mehr Bedeutung und jetzt schreibt der Guardian einen schönen Artikel über die fact Checker die sich Facebook ja geholt hat,
war ja längere Zeit.
Was ist eigentlich dauerhaft Dauerthema die Verbreitung von falsch Nachrichten durch die sozialen Netze.
Deren Algorithmen dazu geeignet sind diesen falschnachrichten.
Auftrieb zu verleihen statt sie in irgendeiner Form einzudämmen und dann hat Facebook sehr,
medienwirksam gesagt ja großes Problem wir holen uns jetzt fact Checker hier mit an Bord und die
da kann man dann den das melden und dann gehen die ihre Arbeit nach und dann markieren wir das oder so und das klang alles nach einer sehr schönen
Idee die sie irgendwann so 20 16 20 17 ausgerollt haben mit 40 Medienpartner und so weiter.
Bunt.
Diese fact Checker melden sich jetzt mal und sagen dass haben ihr sie nicht hinein und das wär hier ernst genommen werden wenn wir sagen dass es hier unwahr dann passiert da nichts.
Wir sehen wie Facebook diese selber noch irgendwie Gerüchte über George Soros in die Welt setzen wollte und das gefällt uns alles nicht so ganz viel fühlen uns hier.
Ausgenutzt und irgendwie als Feigenblätter und das ist auch eine sehr gute Nacht.
Der scheint nicht so gut zu laufen irgendwie dieses Jahr das war eine echte Katastrophe für face.
Ja hoffen wir dass die Katastrophe auch.
Sich fortsetzen.
Ja ihr Ende in einem in einem grünen Abschluss einem Untergang.
Und dann steigt Mastodon wie der Phönix aus der Asche und wir leben alle dezentral.
Männer auf der auf dem ich als Berufs Optimist mehr ich sehe immer dass das Gute in der Alm.
In Facebook siehst du was gut.
In den Vorgängen im Facebook ich meine es gibt jetzt,
wir haben so viel scheiße passiert es so aber am Ende des Jahres kann man sagen es gibt eine Art neue Datenschutz Bewegung in den USA zur ja also das Land beschäftigt
mit diesem Thema und sehr sogar der Apple Chef meint ja also dsgvo es Teil wird einfach irgendwann auch mal kommen geht gar kein Weg dran,
vorbei denke ich auch so und dann irgendwie eine europäische Bürgerbewegung in Großbritannien,
also hätte ich da laufen können ist die Frage mit welchem großen Knall Bumm das jetzt alles ausgeht aber die Chancen stehen ja erstmal so schlecht auch nicht wenn man sich anschaut wie es so um Trump und den brexit so steht also.
Bist du schon wieder so eine 5 € Wette hier.
Mit dir läuft ja noch.
Öffne für Facebook Untergang von Facebook 20910.
Ja dann gut davon habe ich ja nicht gesprochen
also ich würde jetzt sagen so dsgvo in nächsten zwei Jahren in USA irgendeiner Form doch schon mal nen Fünfer drauf legen vielleicht brauchst noch ersten neuen Senat aber so danach auf jeden Fall.
5 € nicht gespannt und dann werden wir nach diesem kurzen Meldungen jetzt endlich bei unserem Hauptthema des heutigen Abends oder.
Oder satema ist China und ja das hat ja auch mit dir zu tun hatte reden ich weiß nicht wie lange das schon her dass wir uns auch unterhalten haben von ja aber das glaube ich in Oxford getroffen.
Von mir aber ich schon in Taiwan das muss lange.
Aber noch länger herum anderthalb.
Anderthalb Jahre ungefähr.
Genau würden uns zufällig über den Weg gelaufen also kann uns schon vorher aber da haben uns halt irgendwie zufällig getroffen.
Du warst in meinem College.
Ich war in deinem College Eiswasser rum und hackte.
Akte vor mich hin und wurde angesprochen genau und dann kam er so ein bisschen auf die Idee,
ob man den nicht mal so ein bisschen diesen Blick nach China richten könnte weil wir berichten da ja hier auch er nur so am Rande darüber und generell lässt sich natürlich feststellen
so das Verständnis um die chinesische Kultur und vor allem das Netz geschehen ist doch überarbeitungswürdig hier im Westen das war,
rasch sicherlich auch nicht denke der Kultur Abstand zwischen dem Westen und China,
Fettabsaugen vor noch was gibt was noch weiter entfernt ist jetzt mal so vielleicht.
Kultur dass ich werde quantifizieren aber es ist schon.
Jawohl aber wir nehmen ja in der chinesischen Kultur relativ wenig
Teil so ja da gibt es irgendwie die Mauer und irgendwas mit Kung Fu und da hört ja dann auch schnell auf so und man weiß irgendwie das ganze giftige Spielzeug kommt von da und die Computer die geilen auch,
na und demnächst dann auch die Autos aus dem die Roller und was nicht alles aber da da ist ja dann irgendwie Ende wir verstehen die chinesische Schrift nicht verstehen die chinesische Kultur nicht und wir verstehen ja auch die chinesische Politik nur im Ansatz.
Das ist sozusagen so das Ding da kannst du ja noch mal kurz sagen was eigentlich so dein konkreta China Hintergrund ist was warum,
spiel das in deinem Leben eine große Rolle.
Also ich bin 2011 nach dem Abi Tucker ich direkt nach Shanghai gezogen der Plan war eigentlich,
das was ein bisschen zufällig und das war eher so II III Lösung und habe dann aber Anja dort verbracht und ich glaube allein dadurch dort mal zu leben und sich damit,
auseinandersetzen zu müssen wie man um die Great Firewall herumkommt und auf einmal dieses Gras nichts ist mehr zugänglich oder Facebook geht nicht Gmail ging zu den Zeitungen aber irgendwie auf einmal war halt alles unbequem,
problematisch und so warum findet alles nicht und sich da.
Warum bist du da hingegangen.
Also ist das ein freiwilliges soziales Jahr also ich hatte eigentlich ursprünglich vorgehabt nach Japan zu gehen oder in dem Jahr gab sie diesen riesigen Tsunami,
und den ganzen Saturn Kraftwerk in Japan und und dann wurde das Programm hat dann nicht geklappt dann nicht okay gut geht vielleicht doch lieber nach China,
und habe dann dort ein Jahr damit verbracht ich habe Chinesisch gelernt natürlich und aber auch als Fremdsprachenassistentin quasi dann dort Unterricht geholfen inch.
Feuerschutz Chinesisch gelernt oder hast du dann.
Dann fasse ich also ich habe nur vier Wochen Crashkurs gemacht bevor ich eingezogen bin aber habe dann auch als ich dort gelebt haben relativ schnell lernen müssen einfach weil ich teils mit.
Das ist ein Mandarin.
Mandarin Hochchinesisch könnte man sagen genau,
und dann habe ich daraufhin einen Bachelor gemacht der ist Jungs wo das ist ne Französisch Uni und der Bachelor ist quasi ein Programm das europäisch asiatische Beziehungen könnte man das nennen,
AWO Essen sehr stark Focus darauf gibt sich quasi vergleichen Europa und,
Asien anzuschauen also ist mein Leben nicht nur mehr sich von europäischen Perspektive aus Asien anschaut sondern man dass man wirklich sich beide nebeneinander ansieht und der Schule hatte viele Leute also viele Studierende aus Asien oder weil eben auch viele Studien aus Europa
und als Teil des Bachelors bin ich dann in meinem dritten Jahr 2014/15 noch mal nach China gegangen habe dort ein Jahr noch mal in Beijing verbracht an der Cinque,
Universität in Beijing.
Und der unter anderem einen Kuss zu Demokratisierung in ein anderen zu intellectual property belegt was beides ein bisschen ironisch ist in China zu machen und habe dann daraufhin,
dann habe ich dann wirklich zum Verkauf ich dann auf Chinesisch Netzpolitik total,
also ich war quasi hooked hat gesagt okay das ist jetzt mein Ding hat dann einen Master in Oxford gemacht indem ich macht aber zu chinesisches habe Souveränität geschrieben habe,
und mir quasi angeschaut habe was möchte chinesische start eigentlich Internet also wie wird in China drüber gesprochen wenn es darum geht,
staatliche Souveränität und staatliche Kontrolle im Internet festzusetzen und zu,
ja zu irgendwie zu manifestieren war danach dann noch mal ja in Taiwan also Taiwan ist nicht Thailand muss man dazu sagen es ist sehr wichtig in Taiwan wird nämlich auch Mandarin gesprochen habt in Taiwan.
Sollte das nicht.
Aber hallo mich haben schon mehrfach Leute gefragt warum ich nach Taiwan gehe um Chinesisch zu lernen weil doch in Taiwan Teil gesprochen wird.
Ah verstehe.
Man muss auch dazu sagen dass mein Nachname Erdteil ist und ich auch in Deutschland regelmäßig gefragt wird ob das bedeutet dass meine Familie aus Thailand kommt.
Verstehe aber ohne Hahne.
Ja genau kriegen auch also wenn du wieder regelmäßig mit H geschrieben weil das muss ja.
Der ist doch gar nicht.
Taiwan Teiler der Cambridge also aber Taiwan ist halt die Insel vor China wo halt.
Aber mit Demokratie.
Genau wo wo er quasi die Eliten mal hingeflogen sind im Rahmen Anteil der Eliten im Rahmen der Kulturrevolution war das ne.
Es war 49 LKW nicht in einen Bürgerkrieg also nachdem der Zweite Weltkrieg in China vorbei war gab es in China ein Bürgerkrieg zwischen den Nationalisten und den Kommunisten,
und die Nationalisten die vorher quasi an der Regierung waren haben verloren und haben im Endeffekt ihre die Regierung mit nach Taiwan exportiert und haben dann,
offizielle Position in Taiwan ist auch immer noch dass die Regierung in Taiwan die rechtmäßige Regierung über ganz China ist inklusive der Mongolei übrigens,
das ist abgenommen und das heißt diesen Seiten späten 40er und 50er dort an der Macht haben auch lange dort Militär eine Militärdiktatur gehabt und mittlerweile haben gibt es dort aber ein demokratisches System mit Walen und allem und nur sehr,
wenn die politischen Kultur war noch mal Anja und dann habe ich ein Angebot vom MRT bekommen dort Doktor zu machen,
und dann habe ich gesagt okay gut dann kann es da muss ich wohl doch in die USA ziehen.
War das nicht so auf deiner Liste.
Ich habe mich beworben also von daher aber es ist ein bisschen die Bedienung von Docter in den USA sind schon sehr gut das muss also was die Attraktivität von seinem Angebot angeht das ist schon schwer auszuschlagen.
Am jetzt wollen wir ja mal also was heißt denn eigentlich Netzpolitik auf Chinesisch dann.
Also nicht Übersetzung.
Auch nicht Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Also kannst sagen OneNote Jones aber das wäre er so ja das ist sind sie die Internet policy ist könnte man Ansagen für dich eher.
Also Internet kannst sagen orange Jungle aber das ist auch wieder.
Da geht schon los wenn man noch nicht machen Untertitel übersetzen kann wie wollen wir denn dann Brückenschlag machen aber wir probieren es trotzdem mal.
Genau.
Und zwar was mich jetzt erstmal interessieren würde ist wie hat sich denn das Internet.
In China denn überhaupt manifestiert also das dürfte ja auch relativ früh mit am Start gewesen sein
wie ist sozusagen das Verhältnis Chinas der Gesellschaft und natürlich auch der Regierung gegenüber dem Netz und wie hat sich das dann bis heute,
im Wesentlichen entwickelt.
Also erstmal interessante fun fact es tatsächlich dass das,
China iss über Deutschland als Internet bekommen es war eine Kooperation zwischen chinesischen Unis unter deutschen und ich glaube es war Heidelberg
die quasi I dot CN Domain gehostet haben und das weil das gab's ein bisschen Bedenken dass.
Also in den Kommunen im Goethe kommunistischen GKK dies war immer noch Kalter Krieg das gab Bedenken den kommunistischen Gegner in Wien halt zugeben dass Gabi Wohnung wissenschaftliche Kooperation ich weiß ich kann dir die Daten nicht sagen.
Ende der 90er was noch früher.
98er war ja also irgendwie daran dem.
Heidelberg nachher ich meine die deutschen Unis haben ja selber eigentlich erst Anfang der 90er im Internet geschnuppert so richtig ja.
Dann was Neunziger das ist für mich alles.
Alte Zeiten naja also ich würde jetzt mal vom Gefühl her sagen eine Uni die dann Internet von Deutschland nach klingt für mich soll frühestens 95.
Gut dann war es auf jeden Fall hat er die ganze Zeit in der Kooperation und das war da wo die erste E-Mail aus China wurde quasi über diese Heidelberger Verbindung geschickt,
und dann ist es aber so dass von Anfang an also 2000 da war der Tenor erstmal positiv also dass das Internet im Endeffekt eine große,
eine große Möglichkeit für china bietet im Sinne von wissenschaftlichen wirtschaftliche Entwicklung aber auch von Anfang an gab es diese Skepsis war die Kommunistische Partei hat eben eine Geschichte mit der sie lange also dieses das dass Sie Informationen kontrolliert.
Und dass Ihnen besonders Information einfach da Kontrolle haben möchte und dass Sie mitbestimmen möchte was die Leute glauben und denken dass zu dieser ganze
der ganz Propaganda Gedanke und schon 2000 hat sie mir dann gesagt dass das Internet eine Welle von Müll mit sich bringen könnte und hat interessanterweise gerettet eine der größten Gefahren
das Internet,
Anti wissenschaftliche informatives mannschaftliche Information und fake-news im Endeffekt sind oder falsche Wissenschaft und eben auch Informationen die nicht gut sind und die sogar den Menschen schaden könnten,
ich habe das was.
Ein Visionär.
Muss man also ich habe Zitat das direktes Zitat habe ich vor habe ich ungefähr einem guten ja oder so zum ersten Mal vor zwei Jahren
hast du mich drauf gestoßen und das war zu dem Zeitpunkt als in deutschen dieser Fake News Filter irgendwie diskutiert wurden gibt dieses Fake News Gesetz und das war schon irgendwie krass die Diskussionen in Deutschland mitzuerleben oder eine Radtour,
was gefährlich Informationen sind im Endeffekt und gleich zum dann zusehen ok 2000 China ist deinem Denken einfach schon länger dran in dieser ganzen Idee das Informationen,
auch als Wasser eingesetzt werden können und ich glaube das ist im Endeffekt ein bisschen der takeover das von Anfang an das Internet nicht nur optimistisch gesehen wurde von der Regierung sondern auch gesagt wurde es gibt diese eine Gefahr,
und ich habe mein sagen dass 2011 war dann im Endeffekt ironischerweise das Jahr in dem ich selber auch nach China gegangen bin war dann so ein bisschen so ein Wendepunkt,
eine wichtiges ein wichtiges Event war der arabische Frühling der in dem Jahr stattgefunden hat,
und im Westen hieß es dann auch guck mal die Facebook Rohvolution und alle so total krass soziale Medien können zu Demokratisierung führen und die Chinesen sind ja nicht blöd.
Was muss man also bloß dass die meisten Leute im Westen kein Chinesisch können heißt ja nicht dass ich in diesem keine westlichen Medien lesen
und als dann im besten über gesagt oder guck mal hier Facebook für zu Demokratie und könnte ja auch in China zu Demokratie fördern annihilieren sagt okay dann blocken wir den ganzen Kram halt einfach und das war wirklich einer der Momente wo
in China dann angefangen wo also es wurde schon vorher kontrolliert und geblockt aber es gab wirklich eine ganze Weile nen relativ lebendige Internetkultur auch in China DIN,
gerade in 2011 z.b. auch auf Tina Rainbow das ist so eine Art Twitter,
die war dort einfach unheimlich lebendig und dann ganz normal bei den arabischen Frühling das war so ein Grund für die chinesische Regierung zu sagen ok die der Westen möchte im Endeffekt die sozialen Medien benutzen um uns,
um uns um 8 Uhr.
Und im gleichen Jahr gab es auch ein riesiges Zugunglück in der Nähe von window das ist eine Ostinato Küstenstadt und im Nachhinein dieses Zugunglücks haben chinesische Internet,
Nutzer innen angefangen dass ich nicht zu nutzen um der Regierung hinterher zu recherchieren zum ersten Mal gab es bei diesen Explosion von die Regierung sagt uns
das ist einfach nur ein Unfall gehabt sie sagen uns aber nicht was der Grund war und dann haben die Leute angefangen Formationen über die Opfer zu verbreiten und zu recherchieren was deine eigentliche Grund war
und im Glas etwa zur gleichen Zeit gab es auch so ein Fall wo es ein,
Regierungsmitglied gab es und Mitglied einer lokalen Regierung und wieso Bürgermeister nivokazi der an auch an so einer Unglücksstelle war und muss dann wohl dann Fotos von diesem Menschen verbreitet wurden wir in dieser Unglücksstelle standen,
die
Leute auf Volvo haben dann geschaut guck mal der hat ja so eine krasse Dicke Uhr an seinem Handgelenk und haben angefangen wirklich Informationen zusammenzutragen was das für Uhren sind die dieser Mensch in diversen Fotos trug auch in diversen offiziellen Fotos und haben dann
ausgerechnet die für diese Uhren Kosten und ob sich dieser Mann die auf seinem Regierungs Gehalt leisten können sollte.
Die Antwort war nein er hätte ein zigfaches von dem verdienen müssen was er verdient hör auf EC Zündzeitpunkt irgendein politische Gruppe zionistin China ein großes Thema,
und da wurde eben zum ersten Mal wo Informationen gekreuzt erst einmal eben zu diesem Eisenbahnen und zu diesem zwischen Unglück und einmal eben zu dieser politischen Gruppe Zion und das war auch,
wichtiger Auslöser dass die Regierung da angefangen hat deutlich stärker also nicht nur ausländische Dienste zu blocken so dass man die gar nicht mehr benutzen kann in China sondern eben auch die eigenen chinesischen Dienste zu zensieren und dort Informationen bestimmt Informationen zu unterdrücken,
und so ab 2011,
sind dann auch gerade so viele berühmte chinesische Blogger gab es einen namens Hanan der hat lange auch sehr offen immer wieder so politische Sachen angesprochen und,
dem Zeitpunkt hat die Regierung ein Effekt angefangen Druck auf diese Leute auch ausziehen also gerade.
Leute die viel Einfluss hatten die haben noch auf das mal Besuch einfach direkt von der chinesischen Polizei gekriegt und mit den wurde dann halt auch geredet das ist uns um sollte vielleicht nimmt er doch mal bisschen zurück und so und das wurde nach und nach dann einfach unterdrückt,
und es gibt auch echt Leute das habe ich schon mehrfach gehört die mir gerade gesagt das war das Ende von Sina Weibo also wo gibt es noch,
aber wir haben schon auf Chinesisch Freunde und Freundin gesagt das ist eigentlich langweilig weil die ganzen interessanten Nachrichten werden dort weg zensiertes braucht man sich nicht mehr an.
Das fing in dem Zeitraum so target das richtig los.
Wenn du sowas sagst wie da kam dann so die Herren vorbei und wollte mal ein Gespräch führen zum Teetrinken.
Zum Teetrinken sagt man in China macht es ist der er schon alliston wäre noch etwas zum Teetrinken Hengeler.
Okay na das erfüllt natürlich so bei uns sofort du dieses Stereotyp des totalen Überwachungsstaat und ja da kommen sie halt daher und dann werden jetzt mehr alle eingenordet.
Ist das berechtigt das so zu sehen oder muss man das irgendwie im Kontext der chinesischen Kultur Realität irgendwie noch anders kontextualisieren.
Ich glaube,
das Wichtige ist da wo die Leute die Leute die von der Polizei besucht worden waren Leute die unheimlich viele Follower hatten also teils Zahlen die man sich ja fast einfach nicht vorstellen kann er soll ich Millionen von Leuten folgen den einfach und die Leute die direkt Besuch kriegen sondern direkt die die hat diesen krassen Einfluss haben
und ich glaube man kann schon sein dass die chinesische Regierung im Endeffekt eine Strategie fährt in der sie versucht die Leute die im einflussreichsten sind die Leute die am gefährlichsten sind,
zu unterminieren und den nehmen wir Reichweite zu nehmen es gibt tatsächlich auch einen Fake News.
Also am gefährlichsten für.
Oder liegt einfach die Mücken die im Endeffekt ich glaube man kann sagen dass die Regierung jegliche Quelle von Autorität die außerhalb der Regierung ist,
ja dagegen vergeht ja genau sie bekämpft dagegen versucht sie vorzugehen dass das sei das Religion oder sei es jemand der irgendwie Pavillon volle aufbohren.
Oderzeitung oder Fernsehen.
Genau aber hätten dieses eine eine große Felder Weise und der Person der geglaubt wird und.
Auch wenn man als normale Person auf einer plötzlich große Reichweite erreicht es gibt,
senfeier nein man könnte es ein Fake News Gesetze nennen ist ein Gerüchte Gesetz und wenn etwas das man postet
eine bestimmte Anzahl anmalen geteilt wird dann kann man dafür belangt werden wenn das ein Gerücht ist etwas das nicht stimmt aber was ein Gerücht ist bestimmt halt der Staat im Zweifel das ist das Problem mit chinesischen Gesetzen,
das Ding ist aber dazu muss man sagen dass der der Staat hat auch kein Interesse daran hat den Leuten zu viel wegzunehmen und das ist eben die so ein bisschen diese Gradwanderung dass es den Leuten ja trotzdem noch.
Sie sollen statt ja nicht hassen dafür,
und alles gibt ganz doll Fanta Forschung dass es gibt paper von 2013 wo sich Vorschau Tatort angeschaut haben was für Beiträge der Stadt dann löscht und es stellt sich heraus dass der Stadt gar nicht mal unbedingt Kritik an der Regierung löscht,
das ist gar nicht mal um in das Ziel also stimmt es ist schon okay dass die Leute den starte mir kritisieren und negative Sachen sagen
das Ausmaß zu dem das okay ist ist auch umstritten weil die Datenlage nicht unbedingt immer optimal ist aber damals und 2013 war die Conclusio eben dass der Stadt vor allem,
Sachen zensiert die zu großen Aktion im Endeffekt aufrufen also alles was die mögliche das Potenzial hat große Menge an Menschen zu mobilisieren unterdrückter Staat im Endeffekt und das ist auch ich glaube man kann das ganz anschaulich dar ansehen.
Es geht aber dabei auch nicht unbedingt nur um politische Sachen aber alles was ihm eine große Menge von Menschen auf die Straße bringen könnte sei es jetzt irgendwie weil es gegen den Staat oder sei es gegen sei es gegen keine Ahnung.
Ehe für alle keine Ahnung der schafft er kein Interesse daran unkontrollierbare Menschenmengen auf der Straße zu haben die gegen irgendetwas Protest,
am es gibt auch andere Forschung die sich anschaut wie z.b. chinesische start mit Anti japanischen Protesten umgeht dies dieses Jahr nicht Ina auch öfters gibt und da.
Oder antiamerikanische auch gab doch mal diese Bombe nicht mal irgendwo eine Bombe auf eine chinesische Botschaft.
Genau das war.
Libyen oder Syrien.
Bosnien Bosnien.
Was mir das genau ja kann sein.
Ist auf jeden Fall Europa genau aber ja und da ist aber auch die Tatsache dass tatsächlich gibt es z.b. wurden so es gibt ein,
Jessica chainwise hat darüber geschrieben und jetzt möchte Fotos von einem Anti japanischen Bruchtest wo aber plötzlich Fotos von ich von einem chinesischen
von einem chinesischen Menschen der hoch und der Partei ist auf die Bilder bei dieser Person gut ist aufgetaucht sind weil der Mann hatte kurz vorher seine Position in der Partei verloren
es wurde aber Zündzeitpunkt gegen eingestellte davon aus dass er die nächste chinesische Präsident wird,
ist er dann aber nicht geworden weil er ist kaputt und hat der Parteien gestresst und dann hat er seinen Posten verloren und wurde wegen Mord und Korruption und so angeklagt und auf einmal tauchte diese Foto von diesem Mann hat auf diesen Protesten auf und das ist halt so ein Bär für Wii.
In dem Moment war plötzlich so eine Menschenmenge da ist kann es instrumentalisiert werden für Sachen die die chinesische Rick die vielleicht von Anfang an nicht erwartet wurden unbedingt zu diesem Protest und ich glaube das erklärt zu ein bisschen warum die chinesische Regierung,
sämtliche alles mit mobilisierungs Potenzial bekämpft weil sobald Leute mobilisiert sind kann sie es nicht mehr Kontrolle,
und da wird es dass es in der Punkt ist ein komplizierter aber das heißt im Endeffekt,
gibt es so eine kann man sagen dass es so eine Gratwanderung gibt zwischen wie erlauben Sachen wo die Leute umso ein bisschen ihre Meinung äußern vielleicht noch aber es darf aleuthen nicht mobilisieren und bedarf es auch nicht zu öffentlich sein.
Das ist also es wirklich ja das heißt es gibt doch genug Leute die auch in,
ich glaube eine Sache die man dazu sagen muss ist dass es halt in China mittlerweile auch wie ich gesagt habe ich viel oder habe mir schon erzählt sowohl wo ist langweilig nur celebrity news und so ein Kram stattdessen sind wir jetzt hat auf wechat dass ist er so WhatsApp mäßig organisiert und ohne hat halt,
von der Zensur Perspektive ist das interessante dass es nicht öffentlich ist ist es deutlich schwieriger für etwas dass etwas viral geht es passiert deutlich seltener,
passiert immer noch aber weil du hat so eine Gruppensystem hast die Leute die so isoliert haben und du hast theoretisch auch so eine Facebook artige Timeline aber du siehst,
wenn jemand was postet du siehst nur Sachen die Freunde von dir gepostet haben und auch was Kommentare und Likes und so angeht die siehst du nur von Leuten mit denen du auch befreundet bist,
was heißt das wäre so als ob du in Facebook Post hast aber wenn du mit Linus Facebook-Fans bist aber nicht mit mir.
Okay dann falls falls - Fake Account hat auf Facebook hätte theoretisch,
könntest du könntest du Linus Kommentare selber könntest ich meine Kommentare sehen wenn wir kein will mir nicht auf Facebook befreundet werden also so dass es ein bisschen dass es dem.
Und ist dass das hat er wahrscheinlich relativ frei weitreichende Folgen oder also in der.
Diese neue Struktur des also sage mal so es gibt ein ganz Asien der Tendenz zum Messenger hin,
also auch in auch in Taiwan auch in Japan entchentanz Südostasien sind messenger Matt-Effekt der locus der Kommunikation aber es macht die 10 es verändert ist glaube ich verändert einfach die Natur der Zensur und.
Das gibt durchaus einfach Gruppensieg also gerade in kleinen Gruppen reden Leute relativ Raiba Politik das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt ungewöhnlich,
ich habe auch ihn schon ich war schon in wechat Gruppen drin wo jemand mal so ein witzige T mitgemacht hat,
hast du da so alles ist aber ganz schön also und mir andere Leute auch schreibt das was diese Männer naja wenn ich das auf Englisch schreibe und in seiner privaten Gruppe mit 15 Leuten wo ich jeden persönlich kenne das ist dann ja egal,
aber sobald es halt größer wird wird es halt ein problematisches alles was ihrem Reichweite hat ich glaube es ist ein bisschen dieses dass die Regierung hat lange so,
wo sie gesagt hat ihr können diesen Bereichen machen was ihr wollt aber lasst uns in Ruhe solange ihr keine Gefahr darstellt es ist kalt in Ordnung und man muss aber auch sagen dass es gerade in letzten 12 eine Tendenz gibt auch gegen diese Graubereiche vorzugehen das hat auch zunehmend auf wechat,
Dakar zensiert wird das gegen Gruppen vorgegangen wird es gab auch Fälle wo Leute
das hängt doch mit dem generellen klimapolitischen Klima in China zusammen das Leute aus kleinen Gruppen quasi Leute meine verpetzt haben also dass jemand
bestraft wurde dafür dass einer relativ kleinen Gruppe und Witz über sie im hin gemacht hat und dann hat ihn wohl jemand das wohl jemand anders,
Büro für öffentliche Sicherheit weitergegeben und dann wurde er im ja verklagt ich glaube es ging darum dass sie mit einem mit einer Teigtasche vergleichen hat.
Das ist ein chinesisches meme ist dass der chinesische Präsident eine gedampft das zeigt hasse ist.
Also das selbe Wort sozusagen.
Nee es ist weil das ein es gab ein Schäden macht auf das so Sachen die so ein bisschen was von Kim Jong Un looking at things haben
wo er sich in mich Sachen anstatt dass er gut oder so propagandabilder halt und es gibt so Bilder von skijumping Nebeninsel Restaurant wo jemand gedämpfte Teigtaschen verkauft dann haben Leute angefangen so Karikaturen zu zeichnen wo
eine gedämpfte Teigtaschen so ein Foto ist das Gesicht von Hiesinger hat und.
Warum sollte sie besser gehen als Trump.
Ja genau also nicht dass ich das muss man auch glaube ich sagen der Punkte die chinesische Internetkultur ist unheimliche bis ich es gibt einen richtig bissigen Humor der wirklich auch von niemandem eigentlich halt macht und der war auch,
glaube ich dadurch dass es halt viel,
humoristisch verarbeitet wird dann irgendwie das dann auch mal die Frage so ist das jetzt muss das jetzt zensiert werden wie politisch ist das jetzt und lange haben Leute es einfach.
Immer noch gibt es diese Graubereiche die Leute noch ausnutzen konnten dafür für diese kreativen für diese kreativen diesen kreativen Humor für Karikaturen und das soll dann einfach weniger sind die Regierung hier zu nehmen gegen solche Sachen auch vor es gibt es immer noch aber.
Ist das mach einfach weil warum genau die kriegen das nachts lässt sich diskutieren wir wissen nicht was entschieden Penis Kopf vorgeht,
aber im Zweifel werden die Daumenschrauben in den letzten Jahren angedreht,
sehr sehr schade ist also es gab halt wirklich so man kann fast sagen dass zum 2. crackdown im Endeffekt dass das vor 2011 war alles wirklich so ein bisschen Wilder Westen und es war super viel los,
dann hat die Regierung angefangen zu zensieren die Leute haben sich ihre Freiräume quasi wieder genommen und dann hat dieser Freiräume Witze gemacht und,
Karikaturen und alles Kim Jong-un ist auch ein running gag dem chinesischen Internet sie nennen sie einen die.kim Familie little fatty one two and three,
und der gibt also da gibt's ja ich kann da auch bestimmt noch irgendwie Sachen raus wir haben kann ich eine von auswärts Folge zu gemacht mit einer Freundin von mir die zum Thema forscht chinesischen - die können auch verlinken,
genau aber super 4 das wird aber wirklich man muss vorsichtiger sein zu nehmen was man ab im politischen.
Hast du denn das abzuschließen Fleiß.
Also wie soll man das verstehen ist es so ich glaube unser Bild ist so ein bisschen dieses ja da ist die böse chinesische Regierung und die unterdrückt alles so und das ist ja der totale Überwachungsstaat und so oder ist,
so das Volk nimmt einfach so hin oder merkt es nicht glaubst du das ist so eine so ein bisschen die Spannbreite in der sich so der westliche Blick abzeichnet wie korreliert das jetzt mit der Realität die du siehst.
Ähnlich anders.
Weniger also ich glaube,
mein Eindruck ist dass es in Deutschland diese Idee gibt das Chinesen und Chinesen sind entweder Dissidenten die direkt gegen den Staat vorgehen oder es sind Leute die die Hände waschen sind und nicht wissen was passiert das ist glaube ich.
Hierzu einfach dass du darzustellen es gibt Chinesen und Chinesen die einfach hier Leben vor sich hin leben wollen erstmal in Ruhe gelassen werden wollen,
die erstmal was das Zensur System angeht ist es so die chinesische Regierung blockt IP Adressen von diversen Seiten also manche Seiten kann man gar nicht erst,
benutzen und aber die Regierung delegiert auch viel davon an chinesische Firmen die im Endeffekt im Hals,
als Antwort auf das was die Regierung ihnen sagt dass sie blocken sollen solche Sachen dann zensieren jeweils auch möglicherweise in vorauseilendem Gehorsam schon Sachen weg blocken,
von denen sie glauben dass die Regierung das vielleicht ich möchte dass die Sachen online sind das heißt da wird schon deutlich kompliziert das heißt es ist nicht nur die Regierung sondern auch die chinesischen Internetunternehmen die vor Ort sind sind im Endeffekt Komplizen in diesem System.
Ja genau jetzt erstmal nur so noch kurz nachfragen also.
Ist ja schon fast in meiner Frage drin gewesen so einfach ist es nicht so das heißt die chinesische Öffentlichkeit ist sich dessen auch bewusst dass das stattfindet.
Ich glaube manche Leute ja ich glaube es gibt müssen Klassen es ist auf jeden Fall Klassen Ding also wenn du.
Eine gute Ausbildung irgendwo,
zum grünen Bildungshintergrund hast irgendwie relativ reich bist du obere Mittelschicht dann weißt du im Zweifel was los ist du kannst auch das Geld ausgeben um den VPN zu kaufen du weißt wie man VPN kriegst und kannst den Zweifel einen benutzen,
es ist umstritten wie viele chinesische Internetnutzer innen einen benutzen am ist das wahrscheinlich so vielleicht,
das 10% ein haben oder so vielleicht ein bisschen wir vielleicht ein bisschen weniger,
aber es ist eher nur ein kleiner Teil der Bevölkerung und ich glaube einer Sache die man nicht unterschätzen darf ist das auch wenn Leute wissen dass die dass die informations Umgebung auf die sie Zugriff haben von der Regierung beschränkt ist.
Ändert das ja nichts daran dass dass die Institute einzigen informations und auf die sie Zugriff haben also selbst wenn du weißt dass Sachen zensiert werden aber du nur auf diese Sachen zu gefasst dann kann das trotzdem alles wissen wie du über bestimmte Sachen nachdenkst,
weil du z.b. einfach keinen Zugriff auf Informationen über Tiebel hast oder ziehen Sie an oder so also das kommt habe ich einfach sehr darauf an mit was für Leuten mit was für Leuten du sprichst,
und bestimmte Leute also manche nehmen das vielleicht einfach hin und sage ok so ist es eben und ich glaube muss dazu auch sagen.
An eine wichtige Frage ist halt wie viele Leute benutzen das Internet in Deutschland um über Politik zu lesen das ist sicher ein.
Teil der Bevölkerung aber ich würde auch sagen dass ein großer Teil der Bevölkerung wahrscheinlich größtenteils im Internet ist um sich Katzen Videos anzuschauen oder Bilder von Hitze oder.
Minecraft Videos.
Genau und das muss man auch sein wenn das kalte der Grund ist dass du ins Internet gehst und dass du online gehst dann ist er das im Zweifel egal was die chinesische Regierung zensiert,
weil Zweifel kann es dir wenn wenn du dich bei Minecraft Videos interessierst dann gehst du heute auf Joko und schaust die Minecraft Videos an und das tangiert dich nicht,
dass die Regierung politische Sachen weg zensiert und ich glaube das muss man auch,
einfach im Hinterkopf behalten dass das im Zweifel sehr großer Teil der Bevölkerung ist und gerade dadurch ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass dadurch dass die chinesische Regierung solche politischen Nachrichten auch schwierig wieder weniger zugehörig macht,
das ist auch durchaus mehr Leute gibt die dann sagen okay gut das ist mir irgendwie zu viel Arbeit,
auf diese Sachen zuzugreifen weil so ein Papi anzuklicken ist dann auch noch mal schwieriger und die Dienste sind nicht immer zugänglich und ab und zu sind sie verlassen ich manchmal sind sie nicht und dann der Service.
Viasit.de das jetzt mal so
es gibt ein allgemeines Bewusstsein das schon in irgendeiner Form an der Regulation stattfindet und umso mehr man sich in so einem Mittelschicht Klasse befindet und sprechenden Bildungskontext
ist das dann schon klar dass das so läuft es wird aber es wird jetzt quasi akzeptiert,
weil ist so oder wird es auch akzeptiert weil es unterstützt wird dass die Regierung.
Das Land so führt.
Ersteres würde ich sagen ja so kann man halt nichts machen das ist so und es ist viel Stress da irgendwas sich gegen zu wehren und in zwei Wochen geht immer das für sich selber aber.
Nobody is really happy aber das heißen hat auch irgendwo noch mal einen Widerstand Potential vielleicht nicht heute.
Es ist glaube ich glaube man überschätzt die viele Leute für freies Internet auf die Straße gehen würden sowohl also.
Das würde ich niemals tun das ist sicherlich eine geringe geht ja nicht nur ums Internet also seine generelle System frage ich wollte jetzt auch nicht servolution die Revolutionen in Aussicht stellen,
nur um einfach so ein bisschen zu verstehen was was da sozusagen die Realität weil da würde ich auch sagen wenn es vielleicht auch nicht ganz so falsch was wir jetzt so sehen.
Ja ich glaube es ist echt aber diese Idee von denen gehirngewaschen Chinesin die alle dumm sind auch nicht wissen was vor sich geht das ist die die Leute wir sind schon sehr genau und was für eins ist also die meisten Leute wissen sehr genau was für ein System sich befinden aber
ich glaube es ist dieses gibt es hier diese diesen Satz auf meine Mutter du kannst nicht wissen was du nicht weißt,
also es gibt die Sachen von den du weißt dass du sie nicht weiß und es gibt Sachen die du nicht weißt ob du weißt nicht mal dass es diese Sachen gibt.
Ja nach Rumsfeld Neville den also an ohne uns und Diana und Anna uns.
Und ich glaube in China ist ist kann man das ein bisschen umschreiben lassen doch die Leute wissen dass es Sachen gibt die sie nicht wissen aber sie wissen es nicht was das für Sachen sind also kannst du vielleicht irgendwie an aber außer du hast den VPN und suchst und Zweifel direkt nach den Sachen,
kannst du einfach nicht wissen was es ist.
Komme doch mal auf diese konkrete Internet,
zinso Infrastruktur die jetzt in China am Status und bevor wir vielleicht da konkret noch mal drauf eingehen vielleicht zu einem tierung also noch mal kurz sagen.
Was sind eigentlich so die Big Player in China die man jetzt auf jeden Fall mal kennen muss also was sind die großen populären Plattform so die quasi so das Äquivalent zu den westlichen YouTube Facebook Twitter etc Kanälen ist Valldal.
Hinterhältig weit geht nicht erreicht.
Alle nicht erreichbar also keine ist das auf Anhieb keinen westlichen wichtigen großen Messenger oder keine wichtige russische Social Media Seite die erreichbar ist noch nicht Ina das ist seit 2014 alles ziemlich dicht.
Und wir sind dann Sorten die Hand aus wenn man da.
Also man kann Weibo benutzen wenn man Lust auf so Gerüchte Kram hat und so celebrity Kram.
Was ist besser jetzt für das da.
Genau so ein Zwitter Ding aber es halt stark zensiert es variiert aber ja das ist ein bisschen Futter mäßig dann,
man dachte ihn aber das ist die Bad gibt die BAT ist Baidu Alibaba und Tencent zu tun wirklich aber die drei großen Konzerne die alles dominieren bei.
Weil du die Suchmaschine Tencent macht wechat.
Alibaba macht Taube auch das ist so ursprünglich wo das immer mit Ebay verglichen aber man kann auf Tauber Wallis kaufen ist so ein bisschen die Prämisse.
Also hier kann man das ja eigentlich nur unter dem Namen Alibaba.
Ja das ist doch so das ist das Unternehmen aber die haben mehrere Plattformen die sie anbieten und dazu muss man ihm auch sagen dass die Unternehmen auch alle zunehmend von ihrem,
ursprünglichen Dings ein bisschen weggehen bei du es sehr groß was so autonomous driving und KING da machen die unheimlich viel.
Also mir so Google Style so.
Genau und Tencent hat mit so einem ICQ Klo und angefangen dass der hieß cube.eu und
damit haben wir sie für die erste messen dort haben das dann haben ihre Leute dazu ihren Nutzern dazu gebracht zu wechat zu migrieren und wie teuer das mittlerweile so einem Monster Plattform ist es gibt Leute die sagen das eigentlich wie schaut das chinesische Internet ist,
weil du in der App ein nicht alles machen kannst oder kannst du Leuten wie folgen kannst Nachrichtenseiten folgen die app hatten App intent außer über die du alle möglichen Seiten,
anschauen kannst die hat Games wo du gegen deine Freundin Freundin spielen kannst irgendwie kannst deine Miete zahlen kannst deine,
Elektrizität und der ganzen Nebenkosten zahlen eigentlich die alles.
Absolut also und sowohl wechat als auch Alibaba haben unter anderem eben auch nur so eine so eine Wallet Option also es ist einmal alipay und dann,
ich glaube wie pay oder so ist der englische Name und z.b. kannst du dann irgendwie wenn du in einer chatgruppe bist über die du den organisiert hast dann kannst du sagen.
Teilen die gleiche Rechnung auf.
Genau wir haben 180/180 Jörn oder keine Ahnung 400 Jahren ausgegeben Teil das mal durch die Anzahl der Leute in dieser Gruppe sind und dann können die halt dort direkt in der App einfach dafür zahlen.
Das muss man sich sagen wie Chat ist um längen funktional als irgendetwas dass ich aus dem besten kenne,
das muss ich einfach echt vor Augen halten das auch viele,
Chinesen Chinesen ein Grund dafür die Popularität dieser Plattform ist einfach wie gut sie funktionieren und dass du alles damit machen kannst und das ist schwer sich vorzustellen wie sehr sich das Leben gerade von Chinesen und Chinesen,
in den großen Städten verbessert hat und dass ihr war seine Bequemlichkeit ist einfach auf einmal da und es funktioniert ein.
Was kann ich was was haben seit zwei Wochen haben wir hier Apple pay.
Aber ich höre nur bestimmten danken und wenn ich das richtige Bankkonto hasse also which also wechat pay ist mittlerweile,
richtig explodiert dass das so 2015/2016 und mittlerweile kannst du wirst halt blöd angeguckt in Beijing wenn du mit Bargeld zahlen willst also und also als S2000,
Sitz
war ich dann auch bei einem Ich wollte mir Kaffee kaufen gesucht ich habe jetzt mit Fell pattern zeigt mit wechat und dann guckst du mich der Typ noch mal blöd an wenn du weißt du kannst nicht immer mit alipay zahlen weil die sind wie verlässlich was heißt das dann nicht nur kannst nicht nur kein Bargeld,
ausgewählt mit welchem Dienst du am besten bezahlen sollst also es wirklich Formen von Integration Herren von der Nutzungsrate her einfach eine ganz andere Dimension als das was man,
aus dem Westen gewohnt und gerade aus Deutschland gewohnt ist.
Bilder von Blade Runner war vor meinen Augen.
Komme doch mal jetzt auf die konkrete Zensur Infrastrukturen vielleicht auch inwiefern dann diese großen Player da auch mit
integriert sind weil da gibt's ja sicherlich eine gewisse Vermengung wat wat geht jetzt zurzeit nicht also hast du jetzt die westlichen Dienste nicht erreicht sind die Inhalt einfach blockiert so facebook.com und so weiter,
error.
Blocking ist alles dicht kann Sex machen das einfach da komme ich Nachrichten die Seite konnte nicht erreicht werden konnte nicht geladen werden irgendwie.
Aber tot uber.
Ist ein geht einfach nicht du kannst auch nicht kannst nicht pingen und nichts ich habe meinen Pin zu Google laufen in meinem Terminal wenn ich in China bin um ein VPN an habe weil wenn der ping tot ist dann weiß ich alle VPN ist gerade theoretisch noch verbunden aber irgendwas läuft nicht mehr.
Wenn Google nicht mehr Ping dann ist man allein.
Genau so ungefähr,
interessanterweise ging es mir spiel Gmail lange bastelparty Clients noch so einer der Gründe warum ich Thunderbird benutze auf meinem Laptop weil ich konntest lange 12 bin nicht mehr auf gmail.com gehen aber du konntest deinen Gmail quasi abrufen und E-Mail-Dienste abrufen über andere Clients,
und das haben sie dann aber Anfang 2015 auch gekillt und das heißt alle Google-Dienste sind
also wirklich alles ist unter dem Google Domäne wieder bis komplett tot wobei es in letzter Zeit immer wieder Berichte gibt das dazu dass es da vielleicht Lokrum geben wird weil Google halt mit Dragonfly gab es ja auch dieses Jahr öfters die Berichte das Google wohl in der denn,
Kulissen stark daran arbeitet wieder an den chinesischen Markt ranzukommen das heißt Unternehmen arbeiten auch ganz klar dafür irgendwie versuchen und wieso ein bisschen,
die IP blocking wieder loszuwerden.
Ist aber nicht so gut Filme für Google haben wir ja auch schon drüber berichtet dass die Mitarbeiter dann nicht so ohne weiteres mitspielen und jetzt Bock ausmachen an.
Interessant habe auch berichtet dass das Projekt wohl so gut wie tot ist offiziell aber inwieweit also.
Wird sich zeigen aber genau so eine Sache die auch wohl es gibt wohl auch die ti auf der Ebene der Technik des technischen blocken uns dann einfach also es würden bestimmte Protokolle werden einfach geblockt.
Also die Packet Inspection richtig reinschauen was läuft da eigentlich.
Z.b. hat Open VPN für eine Weile funktioniert aber dass Person nichts was irgendwie bei Open VPN läuft zumindest auf meinen Stand der mindestens stand angeht,
läuft noch und es gibt auch nur bestimmte Protokolle Dinge funktionieren manche funktionieren,
und das ist auch von Katzen so eine Katze Maus spielen immer so ein bisschen das sind also gerade so kommerzielle VPNs werden öfters mal geblockt.
Und genau dann das ist quasi die komplette Küche Ebene,
und dann kommt die ihr mir der Zensur von den Sachen die noch zugänglich sind und da läuft viel einfach über die vier also es gibt quasi so ein Deal zwischen der Regierung in den Firmen die noch im Kino operieren dass du wenn du dienstbereit stellst dass du dann Sachen einfach Zenzi ist,
einerseits gibt es Direktive die quasi vom Zentralkomitee.
Letztendlich dann aber es gibt von die von Teilen der Regierung an die Dienste rausgehen und die von und die auch einen Nachrichtenseiten rausgehen und dann gesagt wird hier ziehen Sie doch mal bitte das hier also z.b. als jetzt vor ein paar Wochen,
der der Finanzvorstand von Frauen festgenommen wurde gab es eine Nachricht hier zensiert doch bitte mal sind sie doch bitte mal das bei Mourinho festgenommen wurde oder ziehen Sie doch bitte mal das Welt-Aids-Tag ist solche Sachen,
an anderen Tagen gibt es dann einfach so Sachen wo dann gesagt wird okay könnt darüber berichten aber ihr könnt nur Sachen zu lassen die die offizielle Regierung smedien quasi retweeten,
solche Sachen das heißt da kommen dann relativ klare Direktive es gibt auch Forschung dazu ich habe die wurde da hat jemand neulich was präsentiert,
dazu inwieweit die Firmen quasi flexibel sein können was die Umsetzung Versicherungs Direktiven und Jutta ich weiß nicht ob das schon veröffentlicht wurde also der Vorstadt das in Cambridge,
Inhaber präsentiert ich müssen wir schauen ob dass man das nie schon uns tun kann.
Ich habe mal eine Frage die wir tatsächlich diese die Verhaftung der away Angestellten.
Die.
Findet die Gittern zensiert weil das ist jetzt also sowas zu zensieren ist ja echt ein großes Unterfangen und vor allem das so zeitnah aktiv jetzt tagespolitisches geschehen.
Zu zensieren dass das passiert.
Absolut,
es gibt Leute die das im es ist ist es gibt Schätzungen dafür wie viele Leute in der Zensur Industrie arbeiten in die für China es gibt Leute die das sein also es gibt innerhalb der Firmen mit teils glaube ich ist es.
Nicht es immer weiß ja nicht genau was vor sich geht es werden es gibt Teile die automatisch wo zensiert werden das gibt bestimmte,
Stichwörter die eine Zensur triggern auf bestimmten Seiten und das ist aber noch etwas was die Seiten einstellen und ausstellen können aber
die haben wohl sehr wohl auch versucht wieso machine learning Kram zu machen um zu zensieren aber das ist wohl alles nicht erfolgreich gewesen ein großer Teil der Zensur Infrastruktur
läuft wohl wirklich noch über Leute die händisch entscheiden Sachen zu blocken die etwas sehen dass da irgendwie einordnen und sagen ja blocken oder nicht blocken es gibt verschiedene Arten von blocken
du kannst aber komplett offline nehmen du kannst etwas so machen dass die Person dies gepostet hattest noch sieht aber niemand anders ist mehr sieht
kannst du so machen dass etwas nur noch von Leuten gesehen wird wie der Person folgen aber nicht von anderen Leuten
das heißt gibt auch verschiedene Abstufungen das wird wirklich soweit ich weiß größtenteils noch von Individuen gemacht die dann den Hut vor sie vorgegeben ist was sie zu tun haben was sie zu blocken haben wie Sie es zu blocken haben und das machen sie dann händisch.
Verena jetzt Basisfahrzeug beim Ballspiel wechat bleibt von einem aktiven ein Großangriff dieser Regierung Sensor Behörden,
du bist das man in Agenturen die dann explizit diesen privaten,
Plattform vorschreiben wie mit einem bestimmten Inhalt ab jetzt vorzugehen ist ja alle entsprechenden Zensur Schnittstellen und Kommando Kanäle um das dann einfach zu befolgen weil wenn sie das nicht in gelb sind.
Genau wobei bei wechat ist ein bisschen die richard hat ja Wiesel hat also eine Facebook ähnliche Timeline und das heißt Sachen werden vor allem in dieser timeline,
Zenzi.
Du kannst deiner Freundin zu der Link ist nicht mehr du kannst sowieso nicht mehr zugreifen da steht dann in Übereinstimmung mit existierenden Gesetzen wurde diese dieser Inhalt entfernt genau.
In den Chat selber ist es ein bisschen komplizierter da kann man sich wenn man sich für die genauen Details dann interessiert mal anschauen was das zitterst und lappin,
Kanada dazu gemacht hat die haben diverse experimentelle zugemacht wann Sachen in wechat,
direkt im Chat zensiert werden weil das wohl noch mal deutlich beschränkter ist und da scheint es auch unterschied die Regeln für,
große Gruppen und kleine Gruppen zu geben und es gibt wohl manche Sachen die man teilt.
Nicht abschicken kann einfach tatsächlich also bestimmte Bilder wenn man die abschickt dann wird das quasi irgendwie sobald das quasi irgendwie gefragt wurde innerhalb des Systems dann kann man das Bild zum Beispiel nicht mehr schicken also man sieht das dann vielleicht selber noch aber das kommt da nicht mehr bei der anderen Seite an,
sowas passiert durchaus aber da hat das Telefon bleibt glaube ich einfach deutlich detaillierte Reformationen darüber,
was wie genau das funktioniert und das ist hatte ich auch so dass es auch interessanterweise die haben wohl es gibt innerhalb von Richard Wohlen Unterteilung in nationale und internationale Nutzer,
innen das heißt manche Sachen die Leute die in Kanada sind sehen können auf wechat können Leute die in China sind nicht sehen und manche Sachen kannst du aus Kanada abschicken aber kannst du dann irgendwie schon in China nicht mehr sehen mit Details,
also das gibt ein komplexes System von interne Regeln dass der angewandt wird und das ist nicht besonders transparent wie genau das funktioniert.
Und ist natürlich auch so dass ein Problem der Forschung ist auch das,
die Daten über Volvo sind deutlich einfacher zugänglich weil bei Bushalt wie so eine Plattform dass du kannst den Kram einfach und wir runter kraulen
und machst du denn jetzt Nightshot von were wovon Sachen die in die zwei Frauen und eine Stunde später guckst du und schaust ob die Sachen noch da sind das ist bei mir dann einfach deutlich schwieriger deswegen gibt es auch deswegen konzentriert sich der Großteil der Forschung auf Weibo,
aber und es gibt dort nicht weniger Forschung zu Beach hat obwohl da halt einfach dein großer der sozialen Interaktionen stattfindet ist einfach so ein strukturelles und Daten Daten Problem.
Zur Katz aufzuräumen also die ganze Zensur Infrastruktur muss man es in verschiedenen Bereichen sehen da gibt's halt einmal dieses krass harte weg blocken oder eben auch unter Verwendung von die Packet Inspection,
nimm das Erkennen von bestimmten Protokollen mit dem man nichts zu tun haben möchte und dann geht er halt einfach gar nichts Beispiel Open VPN
wird einfach erkannt und dann einfach die kill dann gibt's diesen
diese Direktiven an Firmen so nach dem Motto hier das ist aber mal nicht so schön das macht er jetzt mal schön ein bisschen beiseite oder komplett weg und,
dann gibt's noch eine dritte Ebene.
Ja man kann auch sagen dass es noch so ein Fake News könnte man sagen aber dass die Regierung eben auch.
Quasi Netzwerke mit Informationen flutet
die Leute sehen sollen also anstatt nur Sachen weg zu nehmen sollte nicht sehen sollen werden auch positive Nachrichten in die Netzwerke geflutet
und das ist die die Leute sind in China als die sogar der 50Cent Armee bekannt daran sieht man auch wieder den bisschen rum oder Leute das gibt in China dieses nimm im Endeffekt dass jemand 50-jährige Cent bekommt Verein Pro ich chinesischen compro Regierungs Kommentar den er online schreibt
und es gibt ein bisschen diziay dass es so eine Gruppe von Menschen gibt die irgendwo sitzen und diese ganzen pro Regierungs Kommentare schreiben und mit 50 Cent bekommen habe zahlt werden das ist,
nichts was ist extrem wenig Geld also,
ich glaube ja acht chinesische Yuan sind 1 € oder so ich weiß nutshell Wechselkurs nicht und dann eine halbe Jörn,
kriegen die Leute im Kommentar es ist es war lange nicht besonders klar was genau,
diese 50cm wirklich tut es gibt ein PayPal von 2016 oder 17 von den gleichen Leuten die dieses paper 2013 geschrieben haben,
die sich angeschaut haben was diese Leute denn wirklich posten und es gab lange so diese Idee dass diese Leute die Regierung verteidigen und so Streit online anfangen und Leuten,
also dann so sagen sie hinein gierigen uns voll gut in den Wiesen die so in die Regierung so Streit verteidigen es sieht aber wo aktueller Forschungsstand ist soweit ich das im Kopf habe das.
Die er einfach nur positive Nachrichten posten also die,
gibt ja keinen Gel Schmidt groß Metall mit mit KritikerInnen irgendwie sondern die Posten einfach tolle Sachen über die Regierungen über China und und Fluten einfach alles mit diesem positiven Nachricht,
und das sind wohl teils Leute die irgendwie in,
in Regierungs Inso lokalen Regierungs Position in die Arbeiten des gibt's Anteils als Zeitzone Nebenjob im Zweifel aber da haben auch hat auch das Paper mehr Details dazu weil die diluted halt einfach angeschrieben haben gefragt haben wir bis du und was machst du.
David der Division von Jimin dann auch umgesetzt so.
Genau und gesunde Informationen werden ins ins Netzwerk rein geworfen.
Damit umgehen die bösen Information vorzugehen aber genau also fällt diese drei ich man kann damit sagen dass diese drei Ebenen gibt und da es ihm dann auch einfach die Sache das.
Deswegen ist diese diese Google Sache.
Leute waren super empört dass Google das mache ich persönlich nicht so überrascht muss ich sagen weil die ganzen chinesischen die ganzen westlichen Firmen Facebook und Google versuchen seit Jahren in chinesischen Markt wieder reinzukommen auch Max Ackerbürger gelernt seit Jahren Chinesisch und taucht immer wieder
in China auf und es ist,
einfach so unheimlich ist damit man Fremdschämen sich so ein bisschen wie sehr er sich davor der chinesischen Regierung im Endeffekt zum Affen macht der Chinese ich war auch lange nicht besonders gut ich habe leider keine Aufnahme mehr gehört,
aber ich habe Chinesisch Lehrerin die mir Videos von Mark Zuckerberg gezeigt haben und dann uns gesagt haben der ganze Klasse nicht so.
Ich meine wenn so ein Roboter spricht liegt das halt auch.
Die machen halt wirklich viel um versuchen dieses mag der reinzukommen aber da man halt weiß wie das System funktioniert weißt du dass du nicht im chinesischen Markt sein kannst ohne Teil dieses dieser zweiten Ebene zu sein,
es ist Teil des Deals wenn du in China bist dann sind sie es du entsprechende die Regierung dass dir vorschreibt und wenn nicht dann bist du nicht in Hintern kann halt niemand auf dich zugreifen und deswegen ist es auch nicht überraschend das googeln,
kann sie an diesem separaten System gearbeitet hat und ich würde auch davon ausgehen wenn es Facebook jemals wieder zu uns zum chinesischen Markt bekommen sollte dann werden die auch wahrscheinlich eine separate Plattform bereitstellen müssen wir das Problem ist ja so eine globale Plattform zu haben wo du,
deine Freunde sein kannst du das wird halt also ich gehe davon aus das teamkonzept irgendeiner Schublade liegen haben wie sie das umsetzen würden es ist,
weil sonst ja niemand wird.
Marcel wann zweites Facebook auf gesehen ja letztlich egal.
Genau niemand wird Illusion haben dass sie das machen können ohne zu zensieren und wie jemand der das sagt.
Lügt mein Tattoo dort einfach dem radikal unwissend.
Was hältst du von so Formulierung wie naja es ist ja besser wenn wir präsent sind und damit spielen als wenn wenn es uns gar nicht.
Aber was ist daran besser.
Was nicht das war ja so eine Argumentation.
Sie verdienen Geld ist so schon mal besser.
Na ja so keine Ahnung was Google damit meinte so nach dem Motto wir können dann bessere Informationen die dann doch ein bisschen Freiheit bieten oder stone.
Airsoft also.
Naja das ist jetzt witzig sanny ich sage dass ich sage nur das sind Argumente die Innenraum gegossen.
Ich habe das einzige Argument was man dafür machen kann ist das bei du als die primäre Suchmaschine,
große strukturelle Probleme hat das ist viel
Fake News auf Baidu gibt nicht nur von der Regierungsseite her sondern das chinesische Unternehmen irgendwie zwei schwule irgendwelche Leute in China Geld bezahlen das bestimmt das mazion auf Baidu zugänglich sind ganz ehrlich bei einem großen Fall ich habe auch in der Vergangenheit,
zu Videoinhalten im chinesischen Internet geschrieben und es gab zwei für einen Fall wo jemand,
Baidu verklagt hat weil bei du eine so eine g conversion Clinic so Anzeigen für so eine g conversion Klinik gezeigt hatten das hat jemand versucht weil du zu verklagen gesagt ich könne solche Sachen nicht zu eigen sein Glück taucht immer so Anzeigen von dem wir hin so von so sketchy,
Krankenhäuser in die welche komischen Wunde Heil Sachen anbieten und solche Sachen das heißt du dieses ganze,
ganz ganz Informationsangebot die Baidu ist es da ist sehr fragwürdig und ich habe auch schon von Chinesen und Chinesen gehört die gesagt weißt du weil du das irgendwie so ein Sumpf.
Aber das ist das einzige Argument wo man sagen könnte das Facebook ist vielleicht besser als Facebook Google vielleicht besser machen würde aber halt.
Weiß ich welche zumindest sinnvollere Fake News Filterung Combo ist natürlich dann schwierig ist wenn man von der Regierung selber dann wieder die fake-news gesteckt bekommen.
Genau das ist die Frage also und inwieweit das ist aber nicht alles kommt drauf an wie sich ins,
ich glaube die Sache ist das Problem dabei du sind gerade nicht Regierungs gestalte Fake News sondern so kommerzielle Sachen einfach,
Leute die dafür Geld bezahle dass ihre Dienste beworben werden und so aber letztendlich ist auch Google etwa Seat und wenn es dieses System gibt wo diese ganzen fragwürdigen Sachen beworben werden und Leute dafür Geld bezahlen dann ist die Frage wie du Google da nein sagen,
und das kann man schweißen es.
Wenn ich habe ich soviel so großes Vertrauen daran habe dass sie dabei D-Netz Großwild haben würden aber ich glaube das wäre das einzige Argument was man im Zweifel machen kann ich glaube es ist.
Die Idee dass sie vielleicht irgendwie marginal politische re Sachen posten würden ich halte das für ein Gerücht weil im Zweifel.
Wis wissen sie dass sie wenn sie über die Stränge schlagen wieder zu Lande rausfliegen und das heißt in Zweifel hat Google eigentlich ein Incentive noch strenger zu sein ist die chinesischen Dienst zumindest erst einmal weil sie größeres Risiko fahren da weil sie komplett abgeschnitten werden.
Jetzt,
war ja auch viel im Gespräch dieser Begriff social scoring,
diese scoring Systeme die in China am Start ist und hier überventilieren auch schon wieder alle wegen der chinesischen Leihfahrräder hier auf der Straße dass man dann sozusagen auch gleich noch
Rad seine passende Bewertung in China sich mit einholt du atmest schwer ich merke schon.
Aber das existiert.
Erstmal nein erstmal muss man alles vergessen was man darüber gelesen hat.
Okay ich weiß nichts mehr.
Gut okay als Anfangspunkt kann man glaube ich sagen dass die chinesische Regierung ein soziales Probleme dass sie lösen möchte,
in China trauen Leute einander nicht es gibt extreme wenig soziales vertrauen
weil die Leute wissen dass Leute viel Geld dafür bezahlen dass ihre Fakes irgendwie bei Baidu und wechat geschaltet werden die Leute wissen das vor ein paar Jahren Kalk im,
Bruder gefunden wurden dass die Leute benutzen um Milch für ihre Babys zu mischen Sie wissen von den gesamten Lebensmittelskandalen jedes Jahr wird kommt raus dass eine neue wassermarke irgendwelche Chemikalien drin hat
die Leute die die Gesundheit von Leuten gefährde das heißt und auch auf interpersonelle Ebene so dass du im Endeffekt den Leuten nicht weiter traust als du mit ihnen blutsverwandt.
Warum nennen Warum sind im Rummel die sich dann aber nicht.
Es ist eine sehr gute Frage die sich Sozialwissenschaften arbeiten hat daran sie zu beantworten.
Was ich in Deutschland an sich alle die.
Eine Theorie ist dass es an der Kulturrevolution liegt die in China.
Stadt von innen 60er war das wo quasi jeder jeden denunzierte im Endeffekt,
und du von deinen engsten Verwandten die notiert werden konntest und dann in aller Öffentlichkeit gedemütigt wurdest,
und dass das Imbiss es gibt diese Theorie dass das im Endeffekt das soziale Vertrauen und den sozialen Zusammenhalt komplett zerstört hat und das ist jetzt diese Idee gibt dass du nur den Leuten trauen kannst die wirklich kassiert all deine engsten Braut irgendwie sind und,
ich habe das auch selber wenn ich zu lange irgendwie also immer wenn ich in den paar Wochen oder paar Monate hinziehen aber irgendwann fang ich dann auch in total das nimmt ein wirklich mit weil irgendwie Leute wirklich einander gegenüber gewalttätig sind halt in der in der
Fischinger U-Bahn z.b. das ist,
wirklich ein komplett anderes Gefühl also Leute schieben und stoßen wirklich auf auf einer Ebene die man nicht die ich von nirgendwo anders kenne einfach,
also wirklich so ein bisschen so ein Mangel an Vertrauen und auch ein Mangel an Rücksicht in einer Leuten gegenüber.
Also sein dass direkte Gegenteil zu Japan.
Wie könnte man ja das ist auch über Orientalismus und japanische Klischees Konto noch eben aber das ist.
Ich war da also ich habe es gesehen also der Umgang also so diese aufeinander losgehen und sich prügeln auf der Straße ist jetzt nicht unbedingt japanischen style.
Definitiv nicht und gerade das ist ein das ist ein Puppen dazu kommt eben,
im Internet hat es Problem mit diesem mangelnde Vertrauen eben auch es gibt wunderbare Videos von chinesischen klickfarmen wo Leute wo auf einem Wurf irgendwie,
100 200 300 000 handyvergleiche Video läuft ohne wirklich zu fabrizieren und views und so also es gibt ein bisschen dieses vage Gefühl dass alles Fake ist und eigentlich niemandem trauen kannst,
aber du weißt doch nicht was du machen kannst da ist das ein soziales Problem die chinesische Regierung hat sich jetzt will ich dass sie eine technische Lösung für dieses soziale Problem finden wird wir sehen schon das Problem,
und hat als Teil dessen eben gesagt okay wir brauchen irgendwie eine Möglichkeit quasi Leuten kommunizieren ob sie in der Person in die vertrauen können,
so das ist erstmal die Grundidee in das ist das Grundproblem dass dich nicht regeln wir angehen will.
Das Problem ist dass in der westlichen Berichterstattung verschiedene Sachen zusammen geworfen werden und am schlimmsten das schlimmste was ich in den Berichterstattungen seit Jahren passiert ist diese Black Mirror Folge auf die alle immer verweisen,
weil in der Black Mirror Folge werden die Leute einander und jede Person hat so eine einzelne score,
also eine Nummer eine Ziffer die irgendwie ihren Wert angibt oder so und bei sehen auf dieser Score wenn die Leute dann wird jene Leute Dienste angeboten oder nicht.
Dass die Folge nosedive erste Episode der dritten dritten Staffel die sich aber jetzt nicht auf China bezieht.
Nee überhaupt nicht das ist reine Fiktion,
und das Problem ist aber die Regierung hat 2015 ein paper veröffentlichen dem sie eben die Idee für social credit so ein bisschen erstmal geschrieben habe da gab es schon einen riesigen,
aufschreien in den ganzen westlichen München also hat die chinesische Regierung macht jetzt und wird alle Leute kontrollieren und ihnen Scores geben ich glaube ein wichtiger Punkt Perspektive ist
wenn die deutsche Regierung sagt wir wären in der nächsten Fähre Innovationsland I wichtigste Innovation zu Europas sein sag niemand oh Gott und cyan ist Deutschland das wichtigste Innovation von Europa,
weil wir wissen dass bloß bei dir ihm übers vorhat und das in dem Positionspapier schreibt das ist nicht unbedingt passieren wird.
Da viel auf dem Weg dahin passieren muss und weiter mitspielen müssen uns auch sein dass das Paypal das damals veröffentlicht wurde relativ vage ist es gibt englischsprachige Übersetzung von dem Originaldokument das können wir vielleicht auch verlinken.
So es ist es gibt einen guten breakdown von dem Vorwurf was ist bei dem System gibt von Jeremy Daum das ist ein Rechtswissenschaftler der zum Thema für geschrieben hat,
eine Sache die es gibt sind es so credit scoring es ist einfach so Schufa Meeris ich dann dass die Regierung gesagt hat wir müssen einerseits müssen wir quasi die Region dem es mit den Leuten dabei helfen dass die Bankkonten öffnen können und mir Bushalte Visum Creed credit System,
erstellen wie es wirklich am besten einfach existiert ich mag das jetzt auch wo ich den USA lebe wie krass das da eigentlich ist,
und glaube nicht dass das erstrebenswert ist also Modell zu haben aber das ist halt ein bisschen die dir gewiss dass man sagen kann wie hier wir müssen die finanzielle den finanziellen die ich eine telegram Würdigkeit von Leuten irgendwie,
bestimmt es ist aber das ist etwas was vor allem über Privatunternehmen eigentlich laufen sollte es ist aber so dass die Regierung wollte eigentlich die Zentner Privatunternehmen herausgeben das ist unter anderem der Kontexte dem auch Alibaba
dein Wohl wird es es war aber so dass dann
es auch mehrere Schritte zurück und vorwärts gar bei dem Thema weil die Regierungen festgestellt hat es ist tatsächlich echt keine gute Idee wenn die Unternehmen die Leute selber Sachen verkaufen wollen ihre eigenen Daten nutzen um die Leute zu bewerten wenn ich gibt's da irgendwie,
so Interessenskonflikte und deswegen wurde System Rene mehrmals geändert was genau da jetzt gemacht werden kann und was gerade aktuelle Standes weiß ich dass ich dich nicht aber Alibaba hat quasi sein eigenes System irgendwie,
wo es so keine Scores im Endeffekt.
Bereitstellen bereit steht für seine Leute aber das ist auch alles gerade auf experimentelle eben und es ist gerade nicht so dass das irgendwie benutzt wird in irgendeiner Weise und das sind halt unterschiedlich Unternehmen das heißt sowieso Schufa 1 bis 8,
die im Endeffekt so Kreditwürdigkeit Bewertungen für Leute bereitstellen das ist die erste Sache die zweite Sache sind schwarze Listen.
Auf diesen schwarzen Listen landet man wenn man chinesische Gesetze bricht die sind in erster Linie erstmal,
soweit ich das weiß der einzige Teil des Systems der momentan funktioniert und schon implementiert wurde das heißt wenn du gesetzte brichst kann es sein dass du auf der schwarzen Liste landest und die Schweiz durch die die schwarze Liste beschränkt an z.b. inwieweit du,
gute zip hinzubuchen kannst z.b. hat,
der CEO von der großen von einer chinesischen bike-sharing Firmen die die gelben Fahrräder bereitstellen.
UFO flights ne.
Genau hier.
Ja glaube ich auch.
Okay aber der ist immer Stau.
Wo ist habe nicht mehr aber Garbsen.
Genau die sind gerade in der riesigen Krise das ein ganz anderes Thema aber der ist auf so einer schwarzen Liste gelandet weil eine seine Firma Schulden nicht gezahlt hat ist anna-lina ist einer anderen Firma schuldet und das heißt er darf jetzt keine
aber da keine Flugtickets mehr buchen und der darf in der Zug fährt nur noch hart Sitz buchen weil das versteht GParted und weich sitzt,
du weißt dass es im Endeffekt eine Strafe dafür dass er die Gesetze gebrochen hat,
und es gibt andere Sachen wo Leute bestraft werden dafür dass sie Gerichte nimby Geldschulden und also,
das hat angefangen dass es die man angefangen als sektorspezifische schwarze Listen.
Und zunehmend haben die unterschiedlichen Sektoren auch auf die Liste Zugriff also wenn jemand z.b. Kappes Gericht
Gerichts relatiert schwarze Listen wo wenn du irgendwie,
dein Anfechtungen Gericht ging über nicht nach kommst dass du dann auf einer bestimmten Liste landest und dann gab es welche für den Zug bereit das auf den Reisebereich und mittlerweile haben die wohl aufeinander Zugriff das heißt wenn du in einem Bereich eingesetzt brichst dann kannst du auch im anderen Bereich,
davon betroffen sein vom Prinzip her ist das erste Mal glaube ich.
Nicht besonders problematisch das Problem ist das ist eben auch schon gesagt habe das Problem ist wir die Gesetze in China schreibt und was in den Gesetzen drin steht,
weil es natürlich sein kann wenn wenn du jetzt sagst das zu schreiben dass die chinesische Regierung 1989
auf dem Tiananmen-Platz mehrere Leute getötet oder getötet hat und in die Region hat das ein Gerücht dort ein Gerücht verbreitet ist ein Gesetz verbrauchen du bist jetzt dafür bestraft das ist der Punkt wo es problematisch
und das ist aber vom System her auch von dem entfernt was quasi in westlichen Medien Hasi weitergeben wird es gibt noch einen dritten Teil das da weiß ich deutlich weniger drüber mir ist nicht ganz klar inwieweit das gerade schon implementiert ist und was dazu gibt,
wo die Regierung tatsächlich versucht auch Leute durch dieses,
durch durch dies möchte mit diesem System ist da bist ja dass ihm so formuliert dass die die Leute zu guten sozialen Verhalten anregen möchte ja genau.
Wer will das nicht.
Genau welche Regierung will das nicht aber das prodas ist halt der Ausdruck das ist halt der Punkt wo ist glaube ich das Potential geht am 1.
Dass Leute halt für bestimmte Sachen belohnt werden bestimmte Sachen bestraft werden das Problem ist wenn die Willi das ist der Teil über den hauptsächlich berichtet wird.
Ein Problem ist dass es bei diverse Pilotprojekte gibt die lokale Regierung angefangen haben dir mit dem.
Gesamt chinesischen System erstmal nicht unbedingt etwas zu tun haben also es ist unklar inwieweit die Regierung in Hongkong
wo z.b. kein Strittmatter hat von dort berichtet glaube ich dir gibt es ein ziemlich radikale Sportbrake wo es wirklich so eine einzelne score gibt die Leute und betrifft es ist
in keinster Weise klar inwieweit das repräsentieren wird was irgendwann implementiert werden könnte oder solltest einfach eine Spekulation
gibt ein anderes Ding in Shanghai zum Beispiel wo die Regierung so eine App bereitstellt wo man seine eigene skorin wie nachschauen kann und das ist aber alles immer so grimmig fiziert uns ist gerade,
die Sachen haben gerade kein also zumindestens Hunger soweit ich weiß keine wirkliche Konsequenzen für Leute und es ist nicht klar inwieweit das.
Okay aber auf jeder hat mal fest
es gibt scoring Mechanismen teilweise für ähnliche Ziele wie hier ne also Kreditwürdigkeit erzähl teilweise eben aber auch so
im Sinne von Leute die die Gesetze nicht gut einhalten so vielleicht sitzen sich im Knast aber wer schränkt ihre Möglichkeit ein Geschäftsleben,
oder auch nur am Reiseleben gleichberechtigte Teilhabe zu haben,
könnte aber auch in zunehmendem Maße die Schritte erst ja im Prinzip schon angedeutet aufeinander zusammen laufen und weitere Integration erhalten.
Das ist Spekulation.
Spekulation aber.
Theoretisch ja.
Hat zumindest einteilen ja auch schon stattgefunden ich habe mir das jetzt gerade erst ein ich hatte das gar nicht explizit für diese
Sendung hier bereitgelegt aber das ist so ein Clip der mir entgegen kam vielleicht kannst du den ja mal kurz kommentieren sind 30 Sekunden Chinesisch hier mit Untertiteln die sich dann gleich noch mal vor aber du wirst es ja vielleicht
verstehen.
Das Wetter schwarzen Listen.
Das ist so eine Ausnahme aus dem Beijing Shanghai Bullet train Assist Highspeed train der hier offenbar mit 140 Sachen,
gerade durch die Landschaft maschiert spiel das mal kurz ein aus auf englisch.
Okay ich hatte es in Erinnerung dass es auf Chinesisch war nur mit Untertitel damals hat sich eine englische Ansage keine Ahnung wie soll man sowas interpretieren.
Ich glaube das Problem ist erstmal muss davon ausgehen.
Übersetzung von Chinesisch ins Englische in chinesischen Zügen sind notorisch schlecht.
Die Frage ist erstmal also soweit Informationsstand gerade ist gibt es kein Personal credit ein keinen zentrale credits.co auf die sowas irgendwie angerechnet wer.
Ja der ist es vielleicht nur eine Ansage für die Ausländer sozusagen mit auf Chinesisch gibt's überhaupt kein entsprechendes.
Mein Wissensstand was den Zustand bei den Zügen angeht ist das ist schon seit einer Weile Zug spezifischen schwarze Listen gibt und ich würde davon ausgehen dass es damit zu tun hat aber ich weiß auch den genauen Kontakt wie gesagt dort ist.
Ja hätte ich dir für euch mal zeigen können was mir jetzt gerade eben erst eingefallen.
Ich würde davon ausgehen dass es das ist das Problem ist auch also,
eine Sache hat auch dass es einfach Unklarheit gerade gibt aber das heißt halt nicht dass die Leute das nicht trotzdem also sind sie nämlich trotzdem benutzt wird sowas ist keiner trotzdem gemacht werden hier guck mal zurück kaydet
hast du es auch für ein weil es in China auch vor einmal System promotet wird umgesetzte durchzusetzen und viele Chinesen und Chinesin
also gerade wenn man sich mich anschaut wie auf Volvo sagt es auch Artikel zu den kann ich auch länger verlinken gerade wenn man sich anschaut wie auf Oahu darüber diskutiert wird viele Chinesen Chinesen haben Rettich
positive Meinung anscheinend was dieses Thema angeht weil sie halt sagen gut endlich werden weil diese Gesetze durchgesetzt weil es ist immer Spiel,
Indien Züge bereinigt Rauchverbot ist Rauchen immer Leute in chinesischen Zügen also machen immer Leute irgendwie kam dort den man irgendwie nicht will und wenn du dann irgendwie,
normaler Chinese bist du sagst hey ich will einfach nur in Ruhe Zug fahren dann hast du vielleicht okay ist doch vielleicht ganz gut dass die die Regierung das endlich mal durch das dass es hier ein Rauchverbot geht,
hast du bisschen was von diesem ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen was man da denn.
Aber auch eine aber auch natürlich eine andere Gesellschaft Realität ne also wo offensichtlich die sozialen Normen die diese,
ja in einer absurden Geschwindigkeit stattgefundene Urbanisierung in China wo die einfach nicht mit gehalten haben ne.
Und und wo die Leute hat einfach auf das in den Leuten ist bewusst dass es da dass da irgendwas im argen ist und sie sehen dieses Problem und wollen eigentlich dass jemand dieses Problem auch löst in dieser sollte nicht unbedingt damit zufrieden,
haben das auch das Ding,
und ich glaube man kann natürlich auch noch wenn man irgendwie auf die kulturschiene das und wie machen möchte kann man auch noch sagen ok es gibt auch eine andere Partition davon was die Gesetze was die Regierungen quasi machen es gibt euch das mal Tradition im konfuzianischen
Regierungsstil dass die Regierung den den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern quasi ein gutes Leben vorlebt also dass da noch eine andere,
Idee gibt irgendwie historisch was Regierung macht und was sie machen kann inwieweit man jetzt klappt dass wir alle,
dass unser denken dass ich den Termin jedes aus welcher Kultur wir kommen ist eine andere Frage und Leute sind ja durchaus in der Lage unabhängig zu denken aber ich kann also für mich ist die beste aktive so ein bisschen wenn man selber erlebt vor Ort,
die Schwierigkeit halt einfach ist und ich glaube das sollte auch einfach sehr frustriert sein können davon wenn um sie herum hat dieser ganze Kram verpass irrt und sie sehen ich kann den Leuten nicht trauen die Leute brechen andauernd Gesetze und ich möchte doch nur mein Leben leben und wissen dass,
die Milch dich mein Baby gebe das Baby nicht umbringen wird und dass das Essen dass ich esse mich nicht umbringen wird,
dann kann man glaube ich schon so bisschen verstehen warum Leute im Zweifel sagen ok hey vielleicht ist es doch eine gute Sache.
Aber vielleicht noch mal auf einen aktuellen Fall der ja den des politischen Bereich auch noch etwas streift die ganze Auseinandersetzungen um.
Jetzt hoffe ich dass es halbwegs richtig ausspreche ich sage mal war way.
Gartner in Huawei.
Rebel Rockers betrachtest mir so eine.
Dass er aber kein kein kein weh das nicht daran weil die Amis das nicht aussprechen können vernünftig aber für deutsche.
Jeder sagt gar nicht dass du so ein stummes h dachte ich ist es irgendwie so war kW
jetzt Hammers okay also dieses Unternehmen steht jetzt gerade also nicht gerade sondern gerade noch mehr als du ohnehin schon unter Beschuss weil Huawei
einer der führenden Ausrüster ist für Mobilfunknetze beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich auch für andere Infrastrukturen weiß nicht ganz genau was wir alles machen weitermachen eine Menge und.
Jüngste Eskalation ist ja die Festnahme
der Finanzchef in der Firma in Kanada wohl auf Geheiß der Amerikaner ist was ich ganz genau was sie da
politisch rechtlich überhaupt für Zugriffsmethoden haben wir das dann so interpole oder was weiß ich nicht ganz genau auf jeden Fall fand es statt mittlerweile ist glaube ich auf Kaution
wieder freigesetzt
generell gibt es eine riesen Diskussion darum so dürfen wir denn jetzt unsere neuen schönen 5g Netze die uns ja das Blaue vom Himmel versprechen und
Spitze sogar bis nachts essen gerne trägt ja dürfen wir denn das jetzt hier mit dem Bösen chinesischen gekrümmten machen weil du wissen ja alle die gelbe Gefahr will ja nur unsere BIZ,
abdrehen und Abhören lustigerweise das was man vom Westen weiß dass sie das tun ja also einerseits Noten ist das ja alles wohl dokumentiert wird es jetzt hier quasi den Chinesen,
unterstellt also,
das später ist noch ein bisschen mehr mit rein dass dieser ganze Handelskrieg den Tram vom Zaun gebrochen hat und generell auch so dieses Etwas das ist dann.
Dieses sprachlose Kooperation zwischen dem Osten und dem Westen jemand mittlerweile kommt soviel an Elektronik und und,
ja also wohl das billigste alt auf das teuerste kommt aus China China hat sich also einen neuen.
Reichtum bezw wollten wir das erfüllt Verlassen der Armut für ein Großteil des Landes.
Genau über diese wirtschaftliche Entwicklung auch finanziert trotzdem,
scheint sich diese Region obwohl sie so nahtlos miteinander verflochten sind so auf Tagesbasis,
sowohl was in Produktion und Transport und Finanz Flo betrifft trotzdem ist man irgendwie weit voneinander entfernt und,
versteht sich nicht was machen was machst du aus dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Ich glaube eine wichtige Darstellung ist tatsächlich Woche rum die festgenommen wurde in Kanada erstmal weil das wird oft wieder aus dass dass es nicht ganz klar und ich glaube es ist wichtig klarzustellen dass es dort um Iran-Sanktionen geht,
also das ist basierend auf einem auslieferungsvertrag den die USA und Kanada haben das bedeutet,
erinnere mich gleich noch als der katalanische Staatschef hier in Deutschland festgenommen wurde das läuft ähnlich also das quasi die USA müssen beweisen dass sie auch unter kanadischem recht ein Verbrechen begangen hatte mit.
Und muss quasi Beweise dafür vorliegen und kann dann sagen wir würden gerne die festgenommen wird und dass ihr sie dann an uns ausliefert hier sind die Beweise kanadische Gerichte mussten sich die Beweise anschauen haben gesagt die Beweise finden wir für gut
und deswegen wurde sie oder daneben die Festnahme von ihr veranlasst und genau der die genaue Anklage,
ist quasi das vorbei über,
seine Beziehung zu einer Firma gelogen hat die Geschäfte im Iran gemacht haben dadurch Iran-Sanktionen verletzt hat genau inwieweit das.
Normal ist das mit Leuten so umgegangen wird dir antention brechen ist die nächste Frage weil es da glaube ich deutlich viele eine nicht,
unerheblich Anzahl an westlichen Banken gibt die da durchaus auch gehen seit impliziert sein könnten aber das ist soweit ich das verstehe erstmal die rechtliche Hintergründe rechtlich Prozess und was dabei glaube ich nämlich wichtig ist es sich vor Augen zu halten dass die Festnahme mit diesem ganzen Misstrauen Dietmar Haberl
von der Substanz erstmal nichts zu tun hat aber was ist ja faszinierend findest das kann dass es so darüber geredet wird das ob es irgendwie damit was zu tun hätte.
Na vielleicht hat sie ja auch was damit zu tun weil.
Es kann natürlich sein dass in den USA selektiv unter die Lupe genommen wurde wegen dieser wegen dieser wegen dieses Verdachts,
genau und die der Vorwurf gegen noch habe ist ja so ein bisschen dass man deren dass man die Rene gucken im Zweifel nicht trauen kann weil es im Justyna kommt und.
Da ist glaube ich auch wichtig meins unterscheiden weil du dir wieder eben schon sagtest zu wissen ja dass die NSA gerne mal um dir rumspielen dass es dann Zweifel auch gute Kooperation gute Beziehung mit den anderen five eyes countries gibt,
und das sind uns eigentlich auch die Länder die jeder jetzt echt Hinterhalt daher sind also Australien und Neuseeland haben schon eingeschränkt inwieweit habe ein 5g trials teilnehmen kann der die kanadische intelligence,
hätten sie es sind auch sehr da hinterher und haben auch sehr offen immer wieder habe beschuldigt um die Sachen zu machen und Großbritannien ist ein bisschen war lange so ein bisschen eher.
Nicht ganz so.
Die müssen jetzt demnächst trade Deals machen mit China nicht müssen jetzt wieder ganz lieb sein.
Wir hatten aber auch tatsächlich Frau mir hat schon seit langem in Großbritannien einen gemeinsamen Sicherheitszentrum Ciesielski wo wirklich die Huawei Sachen die sie an groß planen verkaufen unter die Lupe genommen werden,
also da,
ja das gibt es einer ganzen Weile schon weil nämlich groß und angesagte wir wissen ja vielleicht trauen können und da haben sie halt irgendwie ausbaldowert dass sie sich da zusammen hinsetzen dieses Zentrum haben wo die Sachen wirklich untersucht werden um zu schauen ob es dann und wir Backdoors.
Und in ähnlichen dir hat Robin soweit ich weiß auch dem auch auch Deutschland angeboten dass wir gesagt haben okay lass uns halt weit ihr kommst du mir von euch ein guter Kunde von Traumeel und das werden wir haben wir können das oder oder das war das die Regierung das vorgeschlagen hatte ich weiß es gar nicht
es ist von deutscher Seite Wie kam aber auf jeden Fall ist es auch eine Diskussion jetzt für Deutschland das was ähnliches hier quasi ist.
Welche Behörde denn da involviert sein soll.
Jessi vielleicht.
Brizzi teska.
Also wir sie war auf jeden Fall Silvana finden.
Würde Sinn machen da das BSI.
Wann die in den Gierth am ersten zu dem Thema sich geäußert haben weil Deutschland ist soweit ich das jetzt gerade sehe das einzige Land das etwas gesagt hat zu dem Thema was nicht,
in dem Tenor wir hassen Frau war sondern dass wir sie hat gesagt wenn America will dass wir aufhören auf Arbeit zusammen zu Arbeit und deren Ausrüstung zum Nutzen dann sollen sie die Beweise dafür geben dass die Ausrüstung Probleme hat,
und bisher mir keine gesehen sobald die Regierung uns sobald die US-Regierung uns Beweise gibt.
Schauen uns das ansprechend an und mal treffen eine sprechen Entscheidung bis dahin sehen wir keinen Grund Dortmund wie aufzuhören.
Interessante Positionierung na das man sagt zu nah an die erst wenn wir darauf hingewiesen werden ist das vielleicht kaputt ist Ingwer drüber nach eine Methode zu errichten wo man vielleicht von vorne rein das auch aus.
Nee die Frage ist halt so ein bisschen.
Das Problem ist das gefährlich bisher keine Beweise also im Spiegel der Spiegel Online gab es ein Artikel in die Lüge in dem Patrick Beuth geschrieben hatte das die einzige Backdoor die jemals bei Kabel gefunden wurde bei einer NSA Backdoor,
die von der NSA dort installiert wurde.
Das Problem ist glaube ich einfach tatsächlich das dem politischen System China fertig getraut weil das einfach in den USA wirklich die Idee ist das Problem ist ein bisschen das glaube ich mein Eindruck ist dass es,
in den USA so ein bisschen wirklich so ein kalter Krieg ähnliches denken gibt das auf Teufel komm raus wirklich die Technik weiter vom Westen dominiert werden muss und wenn das nicht der Fall ist dann sind wir irgendwie auf dem Weg in neue Dystopie,
und auf diese Backdoors wir hatten wie immer hingedeutet aber meinem Wissen nach gibt es wirklich bisher niemandem was gefunden hat und ich probier mal schon Sachen gefunden hat,
MS wird immer so ganz und Vinos gesagt dass der Gründer von Rami 14 Jahre in der Volksbefreiungsarmee jetzt Ingenieur gearbeitet hat da muss man sagen.
Britta Scheiße ziemlich jeder Chinese war.
Vor dem wenn du irgendwas interessantes machen wolltest Ingenieurs mäßig was hältst Du vor der Öffnung des Landes und dem Kap der Richtung eines kapitalistischen Systems machen sollen also das war halt,
das war die logische Lösung für jemanden der nicht dummes und irgendwie Ingenieur sein wollte was heißt das ist wirklich schwierig dann zu sagen nur deswegen hat er auf jeden Fall Verbindung zwischen irischen Regierung,
damit was man am ersten sagen kann es dass das Problem halt ist das,
das ist ihm das politische System ist undurchsichtig und es ist unklar inwieweit die Regierung Verbindung mit individuellen Firmen hat ist es klar dass die Regierung auf jeden Fall,
gewissen Druck ausüben kann irgendwie und wenn man in China erfolgreich ist kommerziell hat man auf jeden Fall gute Verbindung zu Regierung in gewisser Weise,
die Frage ist dass man einfach nicht weiß was das konkret für diese Ausrüstung bedeutet das ist halt er diese Vagi Idee dass da Gefahr herkommen könnte und es ihm wirklich die Angst vor Gefahrenpotenzial.
Also vielleicht kann ich da mal was zu sagen weil ich ja mit diesem Equipment durchaus arbeite die.
Die Elemente aus denen Mobilfunknetze gebaut werden oder Netzwerke gebaut werden,
die das sind ja auch nur Computer M&S,
ist schon so diese Idee dass es irgendwie eine gezielte Backdoor drin ist wo jetzt irgendwie so ein hier Backdoor XY von dem chinesischen Geheimdienst oder der NSA das ist.
Glaube ich grundsätzlich nicht sowas sich aber da schon beobachte ist dass diese Systeme,
und damit meine ich nicht nur ist eigentlich unabhängig davon von welchem Hersteller die sind das die gerne mal sehr,
dumme Konfigurationen haben oder sehr einfache
Schwachstellen oder auch mal komplexere Schwachstellen aber die haben natürlich welche und bei jeder einzelnen Schwachstelle stellt sich natürlich die Frage ist die,
dort mit Absicht platziert worden oder nicht aber zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt würde ich eher sagen also das was ich eigentlich von egal welchem Hersteller war auch bei,
Huawei sehr,
bräuchten die jetzt nicht noch eine Backdoor einzubauen damit da jemand rein kommt ne das ist wäre jetzt wirklich übertrieben,
Manfred ist ja auch sowieso eher von einer back-door also von einem von einer Backdoor die Wii ein Fehler aussieht und du hast natürlich auch nicht die Situation dass wenn du jetzt sagst,
du orders du arbeitest mit Huawei zusammen dann ist das nicht so das jetzt was was ich als Mobilfunkbetreiber,
hingehst und unser ich bestelle jetzt mal irgendwie 20 was weiß ich folgende Geräte und stell mir die ins Kernnetz oder so.
Sondern das sind ja sehr viel größere Verträge wo auch dann entsprechende Servicegesellschaften hinter hängen die dann auch einen sehr tiefergehenden Einblick in deine
Infrastruktur bekommen wieder Sachen funktionieren mit denen du so oder so über vertrauliche Informationen reden musst,
und insofern kann ich verstehen,
das da sehr viele Faktoren rein spielen wenn man sagt ich arbeite jetzt mit diesem Ausrüster zusammen oder nicht und ich kann genauso verstehen dass da ihr wie politische Spielereien mit drin sind.
Bin in dieser ganzen Angelegenheit ein bisschen vorsichtig wie gesagt weil ich erstens Innenbereich arbeite andererseits weil es natürlich.
Also es wäre auf jeden Fall töricht davon auszugehen dass jetzt irgendwie der chinesische Hersteller irgendwas im Schilde führt und ein anderer Hersteller das unter Umständen nicht tun würde,
ja oder nein ein Unternehmen mit dem du zusammen arbeitest kannst du ja auch ein Mobilfunknetz mit mit Ausrüstung von Samsung bauen du kannst dir das irgendwie mit,
verschiedenen verschiedensten Herstellern bauen und es ist einfach eine Vertrauensfrage und es wird auch über diese Vertrauensfrage nicht hinausgehen ich glaube,
nicht dass es irgendwie ein.
Standardisiertes Backdoor Interface Chinas gibt welches Wert darauf legt der ganzen Welt sein Mobilfunk Ausrüstung zu verkaufen um dann da die Kommunikation abzuhören ja aber,
also es ist auch nicht so dass man diese Geräte einfach kaufen
könnte in den sein Regal mit rein schraubt und die dann problemlos funktionieren um man sicher sein könnt oder man dafür nicht in irgendeiner Form von Vertrauens Austausch mit diesen mit diesen Zulieferern,
landen würde und,
denke schon dass diese US Kampagne da die jetzt da irgendwie stattfindet schon.
Vermutlich eher so eine so eine Handelskrieg Geschichte ist irgendwie zu versuchen zu verhindern dass dieser Hersteller der sehr günstig ist also die.
Rein von der Konkurrenz her wenn man rein ökonomisch entscheiden würde würde man eigentlich nur noch deren Ausrüstung kaufen dann wird wiederum gesagt oh die ist aber verdächtig gering da ist doch bestimmt der steckt doch wieder irgendwie ein Plan hinter.
Ich bin da irgendwie sehr sehr gespalten aber dass diese Geräte spezifische Backdoors hätten das halte ich für äußerst unwahrscheinlich.
Glaube auch also ich finde es,
ich würde dir auch zustimmen dass die politische Einschätzungen ich glaube deswegen ist es auch bezeichnen dass das aus den USA und aus diesem ganzen five ICE Umfeld kommt weil ich glaube dort das Denken ist und Zweifel ist es besser wenn wir diejenigen sind
die wissen wo die Backdoors sind und die in Pfeife Druck auf die Unternehmen ausüben können,
anstatt dass es dich in diese Regierung ist er muss dazu aber auch sagen dass diese Sache mit dem Handelskrieg,
die die dieses fundamentale Misstrauen den chinesischen Tech-Unternehmen gegenüber geht tiefer als das also Obama hat er seine seiner Labs letzten Amtshandlung ja den,
die Übernahme von einem von exxtra nextron blockiert dass es in Deutschland Chiphersteller und wo das kann sie anfingen dass irgend diese Annahme dass.
Jedes chinesische Unternehmen im Endeffekt in Zweifel einander chinesischen Regierung bis und nicht mal finanziell irgendwie in so Sachen also Sachen mit heilig sein kann und,
ich glaube es ist bezeichnend für so ein US-amerikanisches denken gerade wo eben wirklich politisch gedacht wir dahingehend dass ich in diese schon Einfluss und Zweifel gefährlich ist und,
du hast durchaus so irgendwie.
So eine Kalter Krieg Mentalität drin ist eben trotz diese Verflechtung der beiden beschafften diese Systeme auch weil die die Chinesen sind auf,
die chinesischen Firmen sind auf US Chips her angewiesen die kaufen alle bei vorkommen,
Simson teilen und gleichzeitig sind die ganzen US-Unternehmen auf China angewiesen weil sie dort ihre Telefone irgendwie zusammenbauen lassen also es ist nicht so dass ich die beiden Sachen auf einmal trennen lassen aber das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen das Denken was in der,
im politisches Erbe ich mit den USA so gefühlt zunehmend so seit Ende der Obama era und dann zunehmen natürlich dort Lichtverstärker jetzt unter Trump,
einfach vorher und dazu muss man auch sagen was man mit der wirtschaftlichen Sache tatsächlich ist es so dass soweit ich weiß viele Internetanbieter in den USA sich sogar gegen die,
dagegen gewehrt haben dass Frau Bay vom US-amerikanischen Markt ferngehalten wird weil die im genau diese bitte das billige gekümmert wollten haben gesagt das wäre uns total gut immer das nutzen könnten,
und das heißt es gab durchaus Inhalt der USA dich nicht vielleicht wieder darauf zu gefährden.
Aber die du brauchst ja eh deine Netze nicht ausschließlich mit deren Kram nennt man will ja immer man begibt sich da nicht in die
Einigkeit von einem Hersteller sondern man möchte die gegenseitig ausspielen können klar dass man sagt ja weil das haben die,
habe aber von dem anderen Hersteller schon umgesetzt da warten wir jetzt auf Euch oder bei denen kostet das weniger oder bei denen kostet das mehr oder übrigens euer Anteil hier mit 30
Prozent in unserem Netze ihr wisst schon dass wir unser netter noch massiv ausbauen da können wir uns ja entscheiden euren Anteil geringer zu halten oder so.
Aber das eben ich glaube,
das ein bisschen die Sache das ist ja interessant dass ein ich gar nicht zu beobachten dass gerade die USA immer die die die free-market Verteidiger schlechthin jetzt auf einmal damit umgehen,
das auf einmal vielleicht auch nicht nur westlich Unternehmen nicht normal kann ich unternehmen an diesem freien Markt mitmachen wollen sondern auf einmal auf China und plötzlich muss man über nachdenken
wie dumm sag doch mal den Job in 3ds den Leuten wie Vertrauensvorschuss zugeben und gerade kommt von der Regierung eher so ein niemand kann den Chinesen trauen traut lieber einfach nur uns.
Leute kauft nicht beim Chinesen also ist schon wirklich absurd dieser move derzeit werden jetzt einzigen geileren Kapitalismus hat China oder die USA.
Europa sitzt du bist du der Zwischensumme.
Ja Mensch ist können wir wahrscheinlich noch stundenlang weiter quatschen aber ich fand das schon mal mega guten Ende kann man auch irgendwie Max wachsen.
Sowas abschließendes was du hier noch mit reinwerfen willst wo du sonst das Gefühl dass wir hätten wieder alles falsch dargestellt.
Darf ich das eine dass ich die Sache mit den Hacker noch hinweisen.
Die Sache mit den Hacken was was für eine Sache mit den Hackern.
Der Chinese hat alles gehackt das große Thema gestern.
Der Chinese hat gestern habe ich etwas verpasst ja.
Ja schnell alles.
Also den ganzen besten natürlich die in die USA haben wieder zwei chinesische Hacker angeklagt und haben zwei Leute benannt und gesagt wir wissen wir ihr seid wir wissen für wen er arbeitet und ihr habt Industriespionage betrieben,
und genau.
Ich habe das gibt da links und MS haben diverse Länder mitgemacht unter anderem auch wieder 51 aber ich glaube Deutschland auch betroffen oder zumindest.
Ich habe irgendwo gelesen dass solche angeblich teigl auch bei der Veröffentlichung dieser Ansage mitgemacht hätte aber.
Habe bisher noch nichts dazu gesehen auf Deutsch was er sagt was anderes aber genauso es gibt welche aus China gibt es,
Industriespionage gibt es seit Jahren das ist kein Geheimnis,
2014/15 haben die USA auch schon mal so ein ähnlichen move gemacht wie gerade und haben drei Leute angeklagt die Volksbefreiungsarmee generelles waren sind und haben gesagt wir wissen wer ihr seid das hat er glaube ich einfach auch so ein bisschen.
Signalwirkung dass Sie Kassel dass sie gerade gezeigt haben was sie über diese Operationen wissen dass sie wissen wer der spioniert und werde dich nie sitzen Regierung im Endeffekt Industrie Geheimnisse zuträgt.
Und daraufhin gab es ebenso dieses gab es dieses no-spy-abkommen zwischen den USA und China
weil die gesagt wird das ironische daran dass auch so spionieren generell ist ok aber Industriespionage geht nicht weil kommerziell könnt ihr das ja nicht machen,
und weil die USA wollen natürlich weiterhin auch in ganz normal spielen gehen dürfen und dass diese Abtretung hat wohl lange funktioniert das es gibt so.
Hinweise dass dass das lange die Industriespionage diossina raus kam dann wirklich weniger wurde nach diesem Abkommen aber unter Trump oder das jetzt einfach alles wieder weiter eskaliert,
das heißt es gab auch der chinesischen Seite kann man sagen so ein bisschen den Eindruck dass,
USA ihrer Seite des dies nicht mehr wirklich einhalten und das Mindfuck jetzt die ich eine solche Regierung das finde ich will schon seit jetzt auch wieder die Spionage Industriespionage hochgefahren wurde und jetzt heißen die USA im wieder an dem Punkt wo sie sagen okay dann machen wir es nämlich and shaming,
und sagen wer das ist und zeigen euch dass wir wissen wie Leute aussehen.
National Sätze müssen no-spy-abkommen geschlossener war Deutschland nicht so erfolgreich ok godine nachricht dass ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt dass er noch gar nicht gesehen.
Also hat auch Zeit dieses Handelskrieg kommen Zweifel sein das ist Teil der oder Teil der sich deutlich und schnell verschlechtern einen US chinesischen Beziehung ist die wirklich dieses Jahr an absoluten Tiefpunkt.
Ja ich war da ist die USA ja wie die anderen Ländern auch ganz gut dabei alles auf den absoluten Tiefpunkt zu bringen und China scheint da so ein Lieblingsverein zu sein will.
Die gelbe Gefahr sein an.
Ja aber lieber du ihn noch einen Schluss war gefragt hattest.
Ich wollte es gerade er ich meinte nicht glaube der wichtigste Take-Away jetzt eigentlich das ist oft
komplizierter als als es dargestellt wird gerade wenn man nur Überschriften liest oder so erziehe den ganzen Sachen in China das,
ein wichtiger Appell für mir ist eigentlich China ist ein echtes Land und dort leben normale Menschen und richtige Menschen die existieren das ist nicht etwas
auch wenn man das Gefühl dass über China so die dystopische Romane geschrieben wird
geschrieben werden die in wieder Listen und alles halt immer schon schreiben wollten und wenn man wenn die Geschichte die aus China kommt zu sehr irgendwie nach einem Roman klingt dann soll man das gleich noch mal hinterfragen und sich überlegen ob das realistisch ist und man sich selber vorstellen könnte dass man selber in so einer Situation.
Adressen einfach nur Roboterarm mir in den ganzen Tag Teddybären.
Ich habe Sachen gehört schon von Hals von Leuten dass sie bei Chinesen glauben das ist ja also.
Was ist der was ich daraus nehme von dem was du erzählt hast.
Ja es ist ein also es klingt so so platt zu sagen ist ein echtes Land aber in einem Land gibt es eben auch sehr viel Vielfalt und Menschen die dort immer auch irgendwie,
leben und ich habe Beziehung die gerade mir so mich z.b. mit dem,
Leben in der DDR auseinandergesetzt die ja jetzt auch irgendwie zumindest in,
für westdeutsche in sie dargestellt wird als wär das ein ein absolut
unmöglich darin zu lebt zu haben das Land und auch was du gerade an sparst entweder bist du da Dissident oder oder gehirngewaschen oder so und
ich glaube man vergisst in dieser Darstellung und diesen vereinfachten Darstellungen der sind Menschen die die die wollen auch irgendwie mitführen einleben,
und die denken vielleicht nicht den ganzen Tag darüber nach wie jetzt irgendwas anders ist und wie man sie ihr Gehirn noch besser gewürgt,
gewaschen werden könnte oder wie sie den Umsturz herbeiführen sondern die versuchen vielleicht auch irgendwie
sich mit den mit den Verhältnissen irgendeiner Form zu arrangieren haben Gefühle Bedürfnisse Wünsche Ziele im Leben
Karrieren Ängste und nebenbei dann vielleicht auch noch eine wechat Gruppe in der simmer sagen dass der,
ist der chinesische Staatspräsident aussieht wie eine Presswurst oder was oder was war.
Gedämpfte Teigtaschen.
Ich muss ja vorsichtig sein ich ich möchte weiterhin in das Land reisen dürfen.
Vielleicht aber ein letztes caveat dazu wird also schon dass sie sehr schöne Zusammenfassung ich glaube
ein wichtiger Punkt ist dass das der Fall ist für Leute die im Zweifel im Osten des Landes leben und
wenn Leute die die Folge jetzt noch nicht jetzt hören noch nicht davon gehört haben würde ich sie dazu anregen sich darüber zu informieren dass gerade in Kindern passiert wo Chinesisch Muslime in,
im großen Maße in Lager gesteckt werden und wo der Staat massiv gegen Viren Kultur
und ihre Freiheit und ganz grundlegenden Rechte einfach vorgeht weil gerade das worüber geredet haben dass es ein alles ruhiger die geht haben betrifft vor allem den Teil des Randes der nicht.
Jinyoung ist sonst Hintern und die besten beides Orte wo im Zweifel noch mal andere Regeln herrschen als für den osterlind alt ist das Landes.
Wo muss man alles erstmal hinfahren wenn man noch nicht.
Hongkong Hongkong Johnson Shanghai.
Kommt drauf ankommen ist nicht China.
Jenson ist spezielle ökonomischste ich sagte ich glaube dass die Reise von Hongkong am gemütlichsten ist Hongkong Johnson und dann nach China.
Ich würde sagen es kommt drauf an wie schön dann ist China Hongkong es ja.
ZNS eine Spezial spezielle ökonomische.
Aber Teil der Chinese ist rechtlich Teil von die es gibt diverse Spezial ökonomische Sohn diesen trotzdem China.
Bissig ich wollte nur ich weiß auch das Hongkong kein China.
Bauch schon mal ich weiß auch.
Ich habe gerade auch an die Ampel dass ich Mann ist ich würde ich finde abgelegene Regionen unendlich
es gibt sehr viele unheimlich schöne Regionen in China diese abgelegen sind chenghai und der Westen zu Jones unter anderem aber wenn man dort kein Mandarin spricht dann muss man schon sehr abenteuerlustig sein um dort unterwegs zu sein.
Ansonsten für die weniger antworte ich den Gott das wahrscheinlich die Ostküste einfacher,
und leichter zugänglich Hühnern ist eine was den jetzt vorangeht unheimlich schöne und touristisch Rade die verschlossene Provinz wo ist wahrscheinlich auch ohne Chinesischkenntnisse sich einfach etwas einfach also lässt.
Zum erstmal reichen als Reisetipp und er ist ja auch kein reisepodcast auszusehen und machen oh ich dachte so irgendwann.
Irgendwelche Reisewarnung wo Funklöcher sind wo wir wo man nicht hin möchte.
Funklöcher in China.
In China 4000 Meter Höhe du wirst immer noch vollen Empfang haben es ist egal in die neben einem buddhistischen Kloster in der Mitte von Nirgendwo voller Empfang dass es funktioniert ist halt nur zensiert.
Das ist alles von VW gebaut ja das kannst du.
Erster weltkrieg,
breckweg Viktor DAK Antwort war okay vielen Dank für die Einblicke in die chinesischen Realitäten und Unmöglichkeiten.
Dinos wir müssen noch was zum Kongress sagen.
Ja wir müssen noch ich glaube ganz kurz ein bisschen was zum Kongress haben bevor wir uns diesen auch wieder widmen ich verschenke wie jedes Jahr einen Kongressticket.
Verschenks 2.
Oh das ist super das nimmt mir nämlich Sorge ja okay dann verschenke ich 2.
Weil ich habe auch noch eins.
Das auch noch eins wir verschenken zwei Kongressticket das ist super weil das muss ich nicht so viele traurige absagen,
verschicken und zwar ist die Regel zumindest bei mir ich weiß nicht wie die Teams Ticket überrascht mich jetzt an meine Regel ist,
Erstbesuch in der Person einer unter repräsentierten Gruppe.
Und einfach zu machen werde ich einfach dieses zweite Ticket mit in deinen Pool legen und du kannst ja dann auch salomonisch entscheiden ob wir das zweite Ticket jetzt unbedingt.
Das Schöne das schöne für das zweite Ticket ist bei dem können wir die Deadline verlängern weil bei dem ersten Ticket bei der ist die Deadline die ich kommuniziert habe Freitag der 21.12 um 19 Uhr und das zweite Ticket können wir dann.
Gleich sozusagen.
Und dann können wir den können wir das zweite Ticket ja am Samstag den 22.12 um 19 Uhr entscheiden dann bleibt dann noch den.
Zuhörenden genug Zeit sich zu melden.
Ja ok gut.
Von mir aus auch Sonntag das Problem ist.
Ist auch Weihnachten raus.
Na das muss doch ja aber die Leute müssen ja auch nur dir irgendwie sicherstellen dass du da eine Reise dorthin wo anders noch gewinnen.
Mission schon na ja hast ja recht.
Und genau der Link ist in den ist in den shoutouts einfach kurzen Text schreiben und also kurz eine E-Mail in übers Kontaktformular schicken und dann können wir das so machen.
Dann glaube ich muss ja noch ein paar Termine für den für den 35 C3 durchgeben das ist wie ich gehört habe an Tag 1 um 20 Uhr.
Mach mal kleines Freak Show eurer treffen.
Kleines Fischer hörertreffen.
Umfang Spezi.
Wenn ich eingeladen darf ich auch kommen okay danke dann ist er das frisch erörtert.
Will ich mit Linus sogar erweitert ist Freak Schulrat.
Erweitert Fischer der Nähe wo ich nicht hin darf ist an Tag 2.
Wollen vielleicht noch mal ein paar andere Prominente Podcaster podcasterin noch mit dazu.
Meinst du der Böhmermann kommt.
Katrin besoffen Congress na ja und gucke mal bist du auch noch mit dabei.
Ich habe extra gefragt ob ich eingeladen bin weil am Tag 2 ist der junghacker Tag da will ich ja nicht eingeladen der ist ja für für Jung HKR und Jung Hackerin und deren Vorstände.
Bist du nicht mehr so jung.
Jeder Junge der das ist glaube ich nur bis 12 Jahre und Vorstand bin ich nicht also habe ich da nichts verloren freiwilliger ausfielen es hamleys.
Bieten darf von 10 Uhr bis 17 Uhr einziges Workshop programm an,
die Wiki-Seite ist verlinkt denn das Wiki ist jetzt auch endlich online.
An Tag 2 außerdem um 12:50 Uhr der Jahresrückblick den wo ich einer der mehreren Personen bin die den mitgestalten.
Und am Abend von Tag 2 habe ich gesehen was ganz und ominöse sum 23 Uhr gibt's UKW.
Tim stellt ein neues Format vor mit zwei Überraschungsgästen es könnte geheimnisvoller nicht sein.
Genau ich mach mal wieder in neuen Podcast mal schauen was daraus.
Dann an Tag 3 um 20:50 Uhr gibt es einen Vortrag mit dem schönen Titel du kannst alles hacken.
Du darfst dich nur nicht erwischen lassen von Thorsten und mir,
sec für Daten Reisende indem wir uns ein bisschen mit
den damit auseinandersetzen dass das Leute bitte schön dass Hacker bitteschön freie Leute bleiben denn wir wissen ja Vladimir Putin sagt ja schon Hacker das sind freie Menschen sowie Künstler,
die stehen morgens auf und wenn ihm danach ist mein Sie ein schönes Bild und wir möchten dass es.
Lange so bleibt das Hacker freie Menschen sind deswegen wären wir ein bisschen erklären wie Hacker im Knast landen oder sich Hausbesitzer Swiss Buchungen eintreten.
Das ganze ist ein Foundation Stock und vielleicht versuche wir sind bemüht den vielleicht ein bisschen unterhaltsam zu gestalten.
Und dann gibt's noch in der Nacht vier das habe ich ja schon mal angekündigt.
Du kannst gar nicht aufhören.
Schunkelmusik Schunkelmusik gibt's in der Nacht 4 auch da noch mal einen Link in den Schollen Schunkelmusik wird auch heute noch,
eine IP release and im Laufe des Tages ja da gibt's dann für die Fahrt zum Kongress ist dann jetzt dann schon auf SoundCloud.
Wer weiß denn das eigentlich hier was war da was hast du denn zu tun mit dem projekt.
Ja ich weiß auch nicht wer will wurde uns über die Termine eingegossen ne von Erna Besen und rosa Luxus die werden dort Musik auflegen.
Schlafgelegenheiten auch etwas sehr Wichtiges hatten wir letztes Jahr nicht wir haben Turnhallen wieder,
also die gute alte Turnhalle in dem Fall sind es jetzt keine Turnhallen sondern Klassenräume von Schulen,
das Konzept,
ist altgass aber letztes Jahr in der Form nicht das oft Off-Location also für 8 € pro Nacht und Nase.
Gibt es dann schlaf gemütlich Möglichkeiten für Menschen die in Gruppen Unterkünften mit Isomatte Schlafsack klarkommen,
für den schmalen Taler den Blogpost dazu habe ich auch noch mal verlinkt das heißt also es ist auch möglich,
mit geringer Komfortklasse und geringem Geldbeutel hier noch günstige Unterbringungsmöglichkeiten zu zu finden und viel mehr als eine.
Also Mathe auf dem Boden brauchen wir eigentlich auch nicht zum schlafen deswegen sind wir froh dass wir das noch erkämpfen konnten.
Kleiner Kulturbeutel Herr Zahnbürste Werner zu empfehlen ansonsten leichtes leichtes Gepäck weil das muss man schreibt dazu sagen man muss dann auch jeden Tag wieder abrücken weil.
Die hat da jede Nacht zu bleiben das ist leider organisatorisch nicht anders zu erledigen zu müssen wird es dieses Jahr so sein.
Also ihr könnt euch glaube ich schon relativ sicher sein jede Nacht einen Schlafplatz zu bekommen ihr könnt euch nur nicht sicher sein dass es jedesmal der gleiche.
Deswegen immer Zeug mitnehmen also mit geringen Gepäck reisen zu müssen die Turnhalle in die was auch immer das ist.
Aber es gut ist ja wahrscheinlich denn dir hiermit der Stadt Leipzig dass das so zustande gekommen ist das ist unser portwenn in Berlin über die Jahre immer in irgendeiner Form hinbekommen haben und
in Hamburg dann auch und sehr schön dass das jetzt in Leipzig auch klappt weil das ist natürlich dann auch eine Antwort auf diese schwierige Hotel Situationen und,
Butter.
Engeln ja wer also Besitzer eines Tickets ist ist angehalten sich schonmal,
überlegen ob denn eine Engel Schicht nicht genau das Richtige ist um den Kongress sich schön zu machen und auch Alter zum Gelingen beizutragen.
Ja da muss man überhaupt gleich drüber nachdenken das ist so ja also wenn ihr so Zahlen neu auf dem Kongress seid insbesondere dann aber auch nicht nur dann ist so eine Engel Aktivität genau das richtige für euch denn dann könnt ihr Einblicke in
wie dieser Kongress von unten heraus funktioniert erhalten die euch sonst keinen Vortrag geben kann und von daher
ist das auch für viele Leute der ideale Zugang in einer unter Umständen noch etwas schwer zu erschließende Zähne und dann wird es dort auch sehr viel einfacher gehen als ihr euch das vielleicht
immer vorstellt aus dem brauchen wir euch.
Darf ich einen Plug machen,
wir es gibt auch jedes Jahr ein translation Team das Torx vom simultan vom Deutschen ins Englisch oder vom Englischen ins Deutsche oder in ganz andere Sprachen wie schwäbischer Russisch übersetzt.
Gab's schon mal der bundesarbeit dass das translation Team,
im Zweifel immer gerne auch neue Engel mit aufnimmt und das heißt wenn ihr mehr als eine Sprache sprechen in dieser Sprachen englisch oder deutsch ist dann könnte ich auch beim translation Team melden und dort jedenfalls mit Engeln.
Wird dir bestimmte Sprachen oder ist eigentlich egal also könnte man sich jetzt auch zu waschen mit sächsisch oder so.
Knöchel erstmal Deutsch und Englisch ist die Hauptsprachen ich bin nicht teil II III Sprachen Teams ich weiß nicht was da genau laufen wird aber da gab es zum Beispiel schon mal französischen der Vergangenheit und Spanisch glaube ich auch.
Hatten wir auch schon ja genau also erstmal Deutsch-Englisch sie die Hauptsprachen und meldet euch.
Zalando positiver verlinken können ich weiß gerade.
Weiß nicht ob den schon gibt kann sein dass er die vielleicht in der Zukunft in der nahen.
Auf die vielfältigen Angebote von help ccc.de hatte ich ja hier schon mal hin gewesen da ist er jetzt noch eines hinzugekommen und zwar das Team C3 Audi,
das ich glaube ich hier schon öfter erwähnt habe also für Menschen die im autistischen Spektrum sind und akut oder präventiv bei Dingen vielleicht Begleitung suchen.
Ja in der letzten Woche ne Diskussion von all creatures welcome an.
Wo habe ich das schon im Internet ist sehr alles stimmt.
Also erwähnt dass es das Team gibt aber noch nicht dass es jetzt hier auch mit in das Schema eingebunden.
Sind auf jeden Fall dort auch vorhanden und vertreten und aufhält ccc.de könnt ihr euch ja schon mal mit den,
angeboten desszert für die medizinische Versorgung des Wellness Themes für
Konflikte Belästigung und Diskriminierung Bewältigung im weitesten Sinne oder Unterstützung in solchen Situationen so sie denn auftreten sollten das Security-Team.
Und c3iot und im Zweifelsfall bei schweren Konflikten auch die Schiedsstelle kann man sich ja mal anschauen dass es das gibt.
Und damit glaube ich ist alles gesagt was ich jetzt noch mal kurz zum C3 sagen wollte.
Wasser Termine.
Ein Termin haben wir noch.
Müsse mit Musik haben.
Und zwar am 18.01 gerade wenn man so den Kongress die Kongress solche überwunden hat und wieder vor die Tür gehen kann gibt es den Chaostag Nummer 4,
über künstliche Intelligenz und neuronale Netze in der Uni Osnabrück Seminarstraße 20,
und zwar werden dort vortragen Joachim Herzberg und Volker Strübing.
Passwörter in Ruhe erklärt.
Ja das bringt uns ans Ende der Sendung.
Das doch auch schön servieren Warum bist du eine Sendung ja auch vorbei sein.
Dennoch bedanken FIFA noch mal katharinen fürs Kommen,
hat nur ein Jahr gedauert bis wir den Termin mit hinbekommen haben aber was alles was lange währt ne.
Giada sonsten kann man nur sagen wir sehen uns dann hoffentlich auf dem Kongress,
weil ja dann auch da seid was nicht nicht alle Hörer von Logbuch Netzpolitik und wir würden werden dort sein können und wollen aber,
die die da sind und uns irgendwo erwischen wir hatten wieder so einen,
Kommentar in der letzten Sendung muss ich mal wieder jemand nicht getraut hat bei euch US-Wahlkampf kurz rein zuwinken des Kenneth.
Ich finde es dieses dieses wegschaut treffen doch eine sehr gute Idee.
Zum Beispiel das ist auf jeden Fall ein Anlass wenn es dir zum ersten Tag dann schon geschafft habt vor Ort zu sein euch rechtzeitig aus dem Weihnachtsbaum ausgeklinkt hat.
Und dann wäre noch meinen Abschluss Dank für Sven und Marc.
An dieser Stelle anzubringen herzlichen Dank und wir sehen uns dann hören es dann hier auf diesem Kanal im nächsten Jahr.
Das alles klar bis bald tschüss.